I am 50 years old and do you know what I don't want to do on my vacations anymore? Oh probably a few things. I don't want to cram my family into the same one bedroom room and bathroom. I don't want to. No. I don't want us all on top of each other. I want my own bedroom separate from the children, which is why I prefer Airbnb. Because we can all have our space, and then it's like, makes the whole vacation more relaxing. We can go to bed at different times. You know, I can stay up and read,
我今年50岁了，你知道我度假时最不想做的事是什么吗？大概有几件吧。我不想让全家人挤在同一个只有一间卧室和浴室的房间里。我不想。不。我不想我们所有人都挤在一起。我想要有自己的卧室，和孩子们分开，这就是我更喜欢爱彼迎（Airbnb）的原因。因为我们都能有自己的空间，这会让整个假期更放松。我们可以不同时间睡觉。你知道，我可以熬夜看书，
or more likely these days, I go to bed before everybody else. You know what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have a fridge, you have a kitchen. So I'm not calling up room service constantly and having to pay that fee.
或者最近更可能的情况是，我比其他人先睡。你知道我喜欢爱彼迎的什么吗？什么？零食。你有什么我喜欢爱彼迎的？什么？零食。你有冰箱，有厨房。所以我不用一直叫客房服务，也不用付那笔费用。
I'm just like, hey, we pack snacks, they're in the fridge, go get them. Well, everyone, consider Airbnb for your next adventure. You won't regret making the switch from a traditional hotel. Get groceries delivered across the GTA from real Canadian superstore with PC Express. Shop online for super prices and super savings. Try it today and get up to $75 in PC optimum points.
我只会说，嘿，我们带了零食，在冰箱里，去拿吧。好了，各位，下次旅行考虑一下爱彼迎吧。从传统酒店换到爱彼迎，你绝对不会后悔。通过PC Express，从加拿大真实超市（Real Canadian Superstore）订购杂货，送货覆盖大多伦多地区（GTA）。在线购物，享受超值价格和超大优惠。今天就试试，还能获得最高75加元的PC Optimum积分。
Visit superstore.ca to get started. Hello. Hi there. Hi, welcome to our second drink of Halloween. So guess what, Jenna? According to pretty much every online poll, in fact, I didn't find one where this wasn't true, season two Halloween is ranked
访问superstore.ca开始吧。你好。嗨。嗨，欢迎来到我们的第二杯万圣节特辑。那么猜猜看，珍娜？根据几乎所有的在线民意调查，事实上，我没找到一个不是这样的，第二季的《万圣节》被评为
as the number one office Halloween episode. I don't doubt it. I think it's my favorite. I loved our breakdown of this episode because we had Creed in the studio for the entire episode and he shared so many fun things. Well, Ange, I agree and I actually panicked because I couldn't think of anything
排名第一的《办公室》万圣节剧集。我对此并不怀疑。我想这是我最喜欢的一集。我喜欢我们对这一集的解析，因为克里德（Creed）在录音室里待了整整一集，他分享了太多有趣的事情。嗯，安吉（Ange），我同意，而且我当时其实很慌，因为我想不出任何
that we hadn't already shared about this episode. You guys, Angela and I have been dividing up, taking the lead on second drinks and I was assigned to Halloween and I did not know what we were gonna do. I really felt like we shared it all. But then guess what? What? I found my old MySpace blog for this episode. Old tech. Yes and there were several tidbits that we never shared. Are you ready? I'm so ready. Alright first off, Ange, in our breakdown we talked about
我们还没分享过的关于这一集的内容。伙计们，安吉拉和我一直在分工，轮流主持“第二杯”节目，我被分配到了《万圣节》，我不知道我们要讲什么。我真的觉得我们已经全部分享完了。但你猜怎么着？什么？我找到了我当时为这一集写的旧MySpace博客。老技术。是的，里面有几个我们从未分享过的小花絮。准备好了吗？我准备好了。好吧，首先，安吉，在我们的解析中，我们谈到了
your cat costume and how your tail was very hard to sit in. But according to my blog, one of the ears on your costume kept falling down and it was ruining takes. Do you remember this? I do remember this because sometimes I could feel it fall and it'd be flat on my head. And other times I couldn't. And so I would start talking and Oscar would be like,
你的猫咪装扮，还有你的尾巴坐着有多难受。但根据我的博客，你服装上的一只耳朵总是往下掉，这毁了很多镜头。你记得吗？我记得，因为有时我能感觉到它掉下来，平贴在我的头上。而有时我感觉不到。所以我开始说话时，奥斯卡会说，
your ear, you're gone. I'm like, what? But I had completely forgot about that till you reminded me and I was like, oh yes, it was driving us crazy. Well, I also shared that you broke several cookies in that scene that we had together in the conference room. You know the one where you ask me what I brought and I say brownies and you're
你的耳朵，你完了。我说，什么？但我完全忘了这件事，直到你提醒我，我当时就想，哦对，这简直要把我们逼疯了。嗯，我还分享过你在会议室我们一起拍的那场戏里弄碎了好几块饼干。你知道那场戏，你问我带了什么，我说布朗尼，然后你
like really pissed off because you're like same category as you brought cookies? And then I like slam the tray down. Yes! In my blog I wrote this quote Angela kept slamming them down on the plate in disgust during the scene. I actually remember us breaking. I remember laughing because I broke them and I it's got to live somewhere in some blooper land. It must. I mean we talked about how that was a hard scene to get through but I failed to mention that you were destroying cookies with one ear. Now this episode also features the very first Jim and Pam air high five.
非常生气，因为你说你带的也是饼干，属于同一类？然后我把托盘重重地摔在桌上。是的！在我的博客里我写了这句话：安吉拉在拍摄那场戏时，一直厌恶地把它们摔在盘子上。我其实记得我们笑场了。我记得我笑是因为我弄碎了它们，这肯定存在于某个花絮集锦里。肯定有。我的意思是，我们谈过那场戏有多难拍，但我没提到你用一只耳朵毁掉了饼干。现在，这一集还出现了吉姆和帕姆的第一次空中击掌。
Mm hmm. I know we talked about it because I love it. Yes, we discussed it, but we did not talk about how that was an improvisation. That was not scripted, lady. So wait, it wasn't in the shooting draft? No, I can't believe I didn't share this the first time. In fact, there wasn't any description in the script for how Pam reacts to Jim pretending
嗯哼。我知道我们谈过它，因为我喜欢它。是的，我们讨论过，但我们没谈过那是一个即兴表演。那不是剧本写的，女士。等等，所以拍摄初稿里没有？不，我不敢相信我第一次没分享这个。事实上，剧本里对于帕姆如何回应吉姆假装
to be Michael Scott on the phone. He does this impression of Michael, because they're tricking Dwight, and when he hangs up, we do the air high five. But in the script, it says nothing. It doesn't even say Pam looks delighted. And my memory is that John suggested that we air high five to give it a little button at the end. We nailed
在电话里模仿迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）没有任何描述。他模仿了迈克尔，因为他们在捉弄德怀特（Dwight），当他挂断电话时，我们做了空中击掌。但在剧本里，什么都没写。甚至没写帕姆看起来很高兴。我的记忆是，约翰建议我们空中击掌，在结尾给它一个小小的点缀。我们
it the first time and everyone freaked out on how cute it was. It was super cute. It's also the no look. The no look air high five. It's special. It's like, oh these two are in sync. What's gonna happen with these characters? Well this is where it all began. I love it. And then, Angela, according to my MySpace blog about this episode, Paul Lieberstein improvised a line in his scene with Steve that made Steve break. And I wrote that it took Steve two full minutes to recover.
第一次就成功了，每个人都对它有多可爱感到疯狂。它超级可爱。而且那是“不看对方”的空中击掌。不看对方的空中击掌。这很特别。就像是，哦，这两个人很有默契。这些角色会发生什么？嗯，这就是一切开始的地方。我喜欢它。然后，安吉拉，根据我关于这一集的MySpace博客，保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）在他和史蒂夫（Steve）的对手戏中即兴发挥了一句台词，让史蒂夫笑场了。我写道，史蒂夫花了整整两分钟才恢复过来。
And I'm like, wow, how did we not talk about this? I checked our breakdown and sure enough we had not discussed it. I went back, I watched the episode. There are not any scenes between Toby and Michael. It's a deleted scene. I must have written this MySpace blog before I knew what the episode was actually gonna be when it aired. Right, right. So there's this deleted scene where Toby asks Michael for the name of the employee that is gonna be fired so that he can start the HR paperwork.
我当时想，哇，我们怎么没谈过这个？我查了我们的解析，果然我们没讨论过。我回去看了这一集。托比（Toby）和迈克尔之间没有任何对手戏。这是一个删减片段。我一定是在知道这一集播出时实际内容之前就写了这篇MySpace博客。对，对。所以有一个删减片段，托比问迈克尔要被解雇员工的名字，这样他就可以开始处理人力资源文书工作了。
And Michael tries to fire Toby. I found it and I thought we should listen to it. Okay. Michael? What? Oh, what? Michael, do you have the name of the employee you're letting go I'd like to start working on our place Fine
然后迈克尔试图解雇托比。我找到了它，我觉得我们应该听听。好的。迈克尔？什么？哦，什么？迈克尔，你有你要解雇的员工的名字吗？我想开始处理我们的……好吧。
If you are so anxious to see a head roll, it's you There you brought it on yourself too bad Can't say that. I'm sorry. It's a relief. I don't report to you, Michael. I report to the head of HR in New York. You asked for a name. I gave you a name. Now you're not doing your job. Why don't you just resign? I was just sent someone else. You need to have an HR representative. Just know that if I could have fired you, I would have. I know, Michael.
如果你这么急着想看人头落地，那就是你了。那是你自找的。太糟糕了。不能那样说。我很抱歉。这是一种解脱。我不向你汇报，迈克尔。我向纽约的人力资源主管汇报。你问我要名字。我给了你一个名字。现在你没在做你的工作。你为什么不辞职？我只是被派来另一个人。你需要有一个人力资源代表。只要知道，如果我能解雇你，我早就解雇了。我知道，迈克尔。
What line made him laugh? Well, that's the thing. I said that it was some improvisation that made Steve lose it. I was clearly sitting in the background at reception observing this whole thing be shot, but I checked the script and it's exactly a scripted. So I guess maybe the improv didn't make it in the cut, but I do know that if anyone could make Steve break, it was Paul. I feel like it's the moment just very resigned.
哪句台词让他笑了？嗯，就是这样。我说是一些即兴表演让史蒂夫失控了。我当时显然坐在背景里的接待处观察整个拍摄过程，但我查了剧本，它完全是按剧本来的。所以我猜也许即兴表演没被剪进去，但我确实知道，如果有人能让史蒂夫笑场，那一定是保罗。我觉得是那个非常无奈的时刻。
He says, I know, Michael. I don't know. That's my guess. Well, finally, Angela, I shared in my MySpace blog that Rain, John, and Brian held their first ever PlayStation 2 boxing contest during our downtime for this episode. But I guess the episode finished shooting before they could finish the tournament.
他说，“我知道，迈克尔。”我不知道。这是我的猜测。好吧，最后，安吉拉，我在我的MySpace博客里分享过，雷恩（Rainn）、约翰（John）和布莱恩（Brian）在这一集的休息时间举行了他们有史以来第一次PlayStation 2拳击比赛。但我猜这一集在他们完成锦标赛之前就拍完了。
I noted that Rain and John were down to their final fighters. That just brings me right back. I know. Those guys, we'd be in a scene and they'd be like, okay, last take, last take. We gotta go. We gotta go. We're like, guys, are you doing in a scene and they'd be like, okay, last take, last take, we gotta go. We're like, guys, are you doing your boxing match or are we doing the scene? Pretty much.
我记录到雷恩和约翰已经到了最后的决赛选手。这让我立刻回到了过去。我知道。那些家伙，我们在拍戏时，他们会说，好吧，最后一条，最后一条。我们得走了。我们得走了。我们就像，伙计们，你们是在拍戏时，他们会说，好吧，最后一条，最后一条。我们得走了。我们就像，伙计们，你们是在进行拳击比赛，还是我们在拍戏？差不多吧。
Well, that's a really fun second drink, lady. Thank you, I was very excited. Well, everyone, we hope you like this breakdown of Halloween. Like Angela said, it's with our dear friend Creed Bratton. It's a really good one. Creed is so fun, You're gonna love it. All right, here it is. Enjoy.
嗯，那真是个非常有趣的“第二杯”，女士。谢谢，我非常兴奋。好吧，各位，我们希望你们喜欢这次对《万圣节》的解析。就像安吉拉说的，这是和我们亲爱的朋友克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）一起录制的。这集真的很棒。克里德太有趣了，你们会喜欢的。好了，开始吧。享受吧。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Re-Watch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。
We're The Office, ladies. I love it. Creed is here. Creed is here. Creed is in the house. Yeah. This is so amazing. Creed's going to be with us for the whole episode, guys.
我们是《办公室》女士。我喜欢。克里德在这里。克里德在这里。克里德在现场。是的。这太棒了。伙计们，克里德将和我们一起录制整集。
Okay, Creed, you are our first in-house visitor, right? I mean, we've had people call in, but you're our first in-house guest. I'm the first one. I might have a bathroom break or something. I won't be here for the whole thing, but I'll be in and out. We can provide you with a bathroom break.
好的，克里德，你是我们第一位到访录音室的嘉宾，对吧？我的意思是，我们有嘉宾打过电话，但你是第一位到访的。我是第一个。我可能会去上个厕所什么的。我不会全程都在，但我会进进出出。我们可以为你提供上厕所的时间。
Okay, good, that'd be good. We can take a bathroom break. I'm old, I'm old school. Well, I'm old, so that's part of it, you know. I need everybody to know that I've already tiered up twice since Creed has been here. You've said two touching, well, first of all, just seeing you almost burst into tears, but then you've said like five amazing things that have touched my heart already.
好的，太好了，那很好。我们可以休息一下去上厕所。我老了，我是老派的。嗯，我也老了，所以这也是一部分，你知道。我需要让大家知道，自从克里德来到这里，我已经热泪盈眶两次了。你说了两句感人的话，首先，看到你几乎热泪盈眶，但随后你又说了五件让我心动不已的惊人事情。
Well, as soon as I get together with you, it's just back and we're back on the set, you know, and it's all like, oh, I miss you girls. Creed lives down the street from me. I think everybody who knows me knows this. Don't give them my address, please. I won't. Creed's address is. His hidden key is, yes, we are neighbors and it's one of the joys of my life that we're neighbors. I love that you're right around the corner. I love that we have-
嗯，一旦我和你们聚在一起，就像回到了片场，你知道，一切都像是，哦，我想念你们女孩了。克里德住在我家那条街上。我想认识我的人都知道这一点。请别把我的地址告诉他们。我不会的。克里德的地址是。他的隐藏钥匙是，是的，我们是邻居，我们是邻居是我生命中的乐趣之一。我喜欢你就在拐角处。我喜欢我们有——
We see each other walking. We see each other walking. We see each other hiking around the street. We do. Hey! You were walking, was it your daughter's dog? Your son's dog. My son's little Yorkie, yeah.
我们看到对方在散步。我们看到对方在散步。我们看到对方在街上徒步。我们确实。嘿！你在散步，那是你女儿的狗吗？你儿子的狗。我儿子的小约克夏犬，是的。
Your little Yorkie and I hear, hey pumpkin! And I turn around and it's Creed. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. We see each other in the street. We do. Hey. You were walking, was it your daughter's dog?
你的小约克夏犬，我听到，嘿，南瓜！我转过身，是克里德。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我说，嘿，你是一只小约克夏犬。我们看到对方在街上。我们确实。嘿。你在散步，那是你女儿的狗吗？
Your son's dog. My son's little Yorkie, yeah. Your little Yorkie, and I hear, hey pumpkin. And I turn around and it's Creed. And we've also maybe had some adult beverage and Red Solo Pups. We may have. We may have. And we like to do a little bit of what we call the sauce trail and walk around having
你儿子的狗。我儿子的小约克夏犬，是的。你的小约克夏犬，我听到，嘿，南瓜。我转过身，是克里德。而且我们可能还喝了一些成人饮料和红色的Solo杯。我们可能喝过。我们可能喝过。我们喜欢做一点我们称之为“酱汁小径”的事情，边走边喝
a glass of wine. And watching documentaries. Oh yeah. Creed loves anything where like animals go crazy, like planet Earth. Yes, all that stuff. I just love it. All right. Well, we are really excited to have you here.
一杯葡萄酒。然后看纪录片。哦，是的。克里德喜欢任何动物发疯的东西，比如《地球脉动》。是的，所有那些东西。我只是喜欢它。好吧。嗯，我们真的很高兴你能来这里。
We are discussing the Halloween episode. Yes. Right, right. Season two, episode five. This was written by Greg Daniels and directed by Paul Feig, and it is the first episode that Creed speaks. Well, I actually spoke in diversity day. In diversity day, I had lines with Phyllis.
我们正在讨论《万圣节》这一集。是的。对，对。第二季，第五集。这是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）编剧，保罗·费格（Paul Feig）导演的，这是克里德开口说话的第一集。嗯，我其实在《多元化日》里说过话。在《多元化日》里，我和菲利斯（Phyllis）有台词。
Yes, I told her. And they paid me afterwards. Well, the first day, first day D, remember that girl we had the first day D? Yeah. The first season. She thought I was part of the cast at the time. So she came over, we had a little hands and she said,
是的，我告诉过她。之后他们付钱给我了。嗯，第一天，第一天D，还记得我们第一天有的那个女孩吗？是的。第一季。她当时以为我是演员阵容的一部分。所以她走过来，我们有一点互动，她说，
now you and Phyllis just start talking. And Phyllis said, wait, I said, nevermind, it's okay. Nevermind. Phyllis was gonna out you. Phyllis just start talking. And Phyllis said, wait, I said, nevermind, it's okay. Nevermind. Phyllis was gonna out you. Phyllis was gonna out me. So I said, nevermind, it's fine. And so we started, and I started talking about, you know, sacrificing goats or something, you know,
现在你和菲利斯开始说话。菲利斯说，等等，我说，没关系，没问题。没关系。菲利斯本来要揭穿你。菲利斯开始说话。菲利斯说，等等，我说，没关系，没问题。没关系。菲利斯本来要揭穿你。菲利斯本来要揭穿我。所以我说，没关系，没问题。于是我们开始了，我开始谈论，你知道，祭祀山羊什么的，你知道，
trying to tell her what was on her head. Your improv was sacrificing goats. Yes, yes, yes. So you can hear me in the background. And then later, and they said, wait a minute, Creed's talking in the background. And I said, oh shoot, how did that happen? Yeah, how'd that happen Creed?
试图告诉她她头上有什么。你的即兴表演是祭祀山羊。是的，是的，是的。所以你能在背景里听到我。后来，他们说，等一下，克里德在背景里说话。我说，哦该死，那是怎么发生的？是的，那是怎么发生的，克里德？
So they paid me on the side, but they didn't say, but we can't. I said, no, it's fine. It's fine. And then not off camera, then also was the voice for the ride. Yes, for the mining ride. For the mining ride, you know. You are so funny. I think they paid attention to that one.
所以他们私下付钱给我，但他们没说，但我们不能。我说，不，没关系。没关系。然后不是在镜头外，还有就是游乐设施的配音。是的，为了采矿游乐设施。为了采矿游乐设施，你知道。你太搞笑了。我想他们注意到了那一个。
Yeah, you were so funny as the voice of the mining ride. For the mining ride, you know? You were so funny. I think they paid attention to that one. Yeah, you were so funny as the voice of the mining ride. And Isabel was watching that episode with me and she said, Mom, I know that voice. I know that voice. And I was like, wait, you're... Oh my gosh. She was like, I think it's Creed. She? How concerning is she?
是的，你作为采矿游乐设施的配音太搞笑了。为了采矿游乐设施，你知道？你太搞笑了。我想他们注意到了那一个。是的，你作为采矿游乐设施的配音太搞笑了。伊莎贝尔（Isabel）和我一起看那一集，她说，妈妈，我知道那个声音。我知道那个声音。我当时想，等等，你是……天哪。她说，我想是克里德。她？她有多令人担忧？
She is... I mean, I didn't catch it. And then I looked it up and I'm like, Isabel, we do know that voice. It's Creed. Yeah. But anyway, this is the first time where I actually had some serious lines. It was six and a half pages. I remember Kent Subornak threw the script down and said, okay, here it is. This is your moment. Wow.
她是……我的意思是，我没注意到。然后我查了一下，我说，伊莎贝尔，我们确实知道那个声音。是克里德。是的。但无论如何，这是我第一次真正有了一些重要的台词。有六页半。我记得肯特·苏博纳克（Kent Subornak）把剧本扔下说，好吧，就是这个。这是你的时刻。哇。
And I had memorized it forwards and backwards. I had set a timer on a little recorder at a night subliminally at two and three in the morning, that would go off and play the lines while I was sleeping. I had it backwards and forwards, no joke. I had it backwards. I knew this was the Rubicon. This is the place that I was gonna get, because my intuition said this is it.
我把它背得滚瓜烂熟。我在晚上睡觉时，在小录音机上设了一个定时器，潜意识里在凌晨两点和三点，它会播放这些台词。我把它背得滚瓜烂熟，没开玩笑。我把它背得滚瓜烂熟。我知道这是卢比孔河。这是我将要获得的地方，因为我的直觉告诉我就是这个。
And then of course we walk in the office and Greg came in and said, by the way we've made changes of course to the lines and we've reversed them around and added some new stuff. You okay Steve? He goes, yeah, fine. I go, oh. Because they used to do that to us all the time. All the time. We would come in and you just get new pages and then shoot the scene five minutes later. Yeah, they would hand you the pages and sometimes we've talked about this, the pages would be hot because they just came... Right off the copier. Right off the copier. And we'd drop them some and go, ow, ow, ow, ow.
然后当然我们走进办公室，格雷格进来说，顺便说一下，我们当然对台词做了修改，我们把它们颠倒过来，加了一些新东西。你还好吗，史蒂夫？他说，是的，很好。我说，哦。因为他们过去总是那样对我们。总是。我们会进来，你只是拿到新页面，然后五分钟后拍那场戏。是的，他们会把页面递给你，有时我们谈过这个，页面会很烫，因为它们刚……从复印机里出来。刚从复印机里出来。我们会掉落一些然后说，哎哟，哎哟，哎哟，哎哟。
Now change your lines that you have learned and you've been having a tape recorder play at three in the morning to you. Do you remember the backdrop there right off of where my desk and Kate's desk was and it was the screen there. So you could walk, you could sneak around the back and get to the green room from behind it, you know, that That set up like that. I walked back like that after they told me this and put my hands up and said, okay, here it is.
现在改变你已经学会的台词，而且你凌晨三点还在用录音机播放给你听。你还记得我桌子和凯特（Kate）桌子后面的背景吗，那里有个屏幕。所以你可以走，你可以从后面溜过去，从后面到休息室，你知道，那个设置就像那样。我像那样走回去，举起手说，好吧，就是这个。
And I said, I've come this far, I'm gonna do this. And once we started that with Steve, it was like into battle, you know? And there was some improvisation on that scene because I was paraphrasing my lines because I was desperate. Well, you knocked it out of the park, Creed. Yeah, yeah. on that scene because I was paraphrasing my lines because I was desperate. Well you knocked it out of the park, Creed.
我说，我已经走到这一步了，我要做这个。一旦我们和史蒂夫开始那样，就像进入战斗，你知道吗？那场戏里有一些即兴表演，因为我在改写我的台词，因为我当时很绝望。嗯，你表现得太棒了，克里德。是的，是的。那场戏里因为我在改写我的台词，因为我当时很绝望。嗯，你表现得太棒了，克里德。
Yeah, yeah. Well Creed, you started out as a musician. Yep. And a very long successful career as a musician. How did you even end up on the show in the first place as our stand in slash background person? Background person. I was working on Bernie Mac and Ken Quapus came on to direct an episode,
是的，是的。嗯，克里德，你最初是一名音乐家。是的。而且作为音乐家有很长且成功的职业生涯。你最初是怎么作为我们的替身/背景人员进入这个节目的？背景人员。我当时在拍《伯尼·麦克秀》（Bernie Mac），肯·夸普斯（Ken Kwapis）来导演一集，
and they'd been using me for all these little vignettes and where I was doing funny. And if you ever watch old Bernie Mac, you'll see me all the time in the background mugging up. I really want to see that. I want to go back. I'm always in the background doing some stupid stuff, and they just allow me,
他们一直用我拍所有这些小片段，我在那里做搞笑动作。如果你看过老《伯尼·麦克秀》，你会一直看到我在背景里做鬼脸。我真的很想看那个。我想回去。我总是在背景里做一些愚蠢的事情，他们只是允许我，
because I made Bernie laugh. I want to go back. I'm always in the background doing some stupid stuff, but they don't allow me because I made Bernie laugh. I made them laugh. And so Ken was talking about this guy's funny and he heard from Joe Moore, the first AD that I was in the grassroots. So he sent to Amoeba for some albums for me to sign because he was a big grassroots fan. And we started talking and talked about music and he's very knowledgeable. Then I found out that he was doing the Office of American Workplace and I was a big fan of the Ricky Gervais show.
因为我让伯尼笑了。我想回去。我总是在背景里做一些愚蠢的事情，但他们不允许我，因为我让伯尼笑了。我让他们笑了。所以肯谈到这个家伙很有趣，他从第一助理导演乔·摩尔（Joe Moore）那里听说我在Grassroots乐队。所以他寄了一些专辑到Amoeba让我签名，因为他是Grassroots的忠实粉丝。我们开始交谈，谈论音乐，他知识非常渊博。然后我发现他在做《办公室》美国职场版，我是瑞奇·热维斯（Ricky Gervais）节目的忠实粉丝。
He gave me his number. Now, I've never ever called anybody like that before. I called him as my intuition said, this feels right. This feels right. And Ken would not have given you his number. I feel like Ken is so discerning. Oh my God. If he didn't mean call me. Yeah, so he did. And so he talked to Greg and then I talked to Ken later and he said,
他给了我他的号码。现在，我以前从来没给那样的人打过电话。我给打了电话，因为我的直觉告诉我，这感觉是对的。这感觉是对的。肯本来不会给你他的号码的。我觉得肯非常有眼光。天哪。如果他不是认真的，别给我打电话。是的，所以他确实给了。然后他跟格雷格谈了，后来我跟肯谈了，他说，
I talked to Greg, I told him you're a very interesting and funny guy. And he said, well, what we'll do, and this is his words, Greg's words, we'll put him in the background and see if we can work him in the mix. And that first time that was it, working in the mix. That's all I need to hear. That's why I took liberties just kind of like pretending that I was part of the group and that paid off, you know? Yes. Oh, I love that. Oh, that is so cool. That is awesome. What's next? Should we do a summary? Jenna, do you have one? You know I do. Yes. So in this episode, Halloween, Michael
我跟格雷格谈了，我告诉他你是一个非常有趣和有意思的家伙。他说，好吧，我们要做的，这是他的原话，格雷格的原话，我们会把他放在背景里，看看能不能把他融入其中。那第一次就是那样，融入其中。我只需要听到这个。这就是为什么我采取了一些自由，假装我是团队的一部分，这得到了回报，你知道吗？是的。哦，我喜欢那个。哦，那太酷了。那太棒了。接下来是什么？我们应该做一个总结吗？珍娜，你有一个吗？你知道我有。是的。所以这一集，《万圣节》，迈克尔
is told that he must fire someone during the month of October due to cutbacks at Dunder Mifflin. But in true Michael fashion, he waits until the very last day of October, which also happens to be Halloween. He also has no idea who to fire. He has not made a decision. He spends the entire episode trying to figure out
被告知由于邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的裁员，他必须在十月份解雇某人。但按照迈克尔的典型风格，他一直等到十月的最后一天，那天恰好也是万圣节。他也不知道该解雇谁。他还没做出决定。他花了整整一集时间试图弄清楚
what to do while the rest of us are dressed in our costumes for the Halloween party. I love that. I love that. I love the juxtaposition of that someone is gonna get fired while wearing a ridiculous costume. And they're gonna have to go home fired in that outfit. Well, I have a fast fact about this episode.
该做什么，而我们其他人正穿着万圣节派对的服装。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。我喜欢这种并置，有人要被解雇了，同时还穿着荒谬的服装。他们得穿着那身行头被解雇回家。嗯，关于这一集我有一个快速事实。
Fast fact number one, Greg Daniels wrote this episode and he told me that the inspiration for this episode was that he had always wanted to do a story about someone being fired, but from the point of view of the boss rather than the employee. He felt like we always see stories of people being fired and how they're wrestling with having been fired,
快速事实一，格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧了这一集，他告诉我这一集的灵感是他一直想写一个关于某人被解雇的故事，但从老板的角度而不是员工的角度。他觉得我们总是看到人们被解雇的故事，以及他们如何纠结于被解雇，
but he was like, you never see what it does to the boss. That's the genius of Greg Daniels right there. Absolutely. Well, the problem that this plot presented for Greg was that he was going to have to fire someone on the show. He was gonna have to pick a Dunder Mifflin employee to be part of the plot.
但他当时想，你从来没看到这对老板有什么影响。这就是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的才华所在。绝对是。嗯，这个情节给格雷格带来的问题是他必须在节目中解雇某人。他必须挑选一名邓德·米夫林的员工来参与这个情节。
Well, he couldn't fire any of the series regular characters because we all had contracts, and he didn't wanna fire any of the series regular characters because we all had contracts and he didn't want to fire any of the supporting cast even though at this point you guys still did not have your full-time contracts, right? No, we didn't. We didn't become series regulars till booze crews. So listen, we were all on the chopping block. Were you a little worried? Well, maybe. Well, Greg didn't have any intention of losing them. He didn't want to lose anyone in the warehouse. But he also told me he didn't want to hire someone new that you'd never seen on the show just to fire them.
嗯，他不能解雇任何系列常规角色，因为我们都有合同，他不想解雇任何配角，尽管当时你们还没有全职合同，对吧？不，我们没有。直到《酒会》那一集我们才成为系列常规演员。所以听着，我们都在被裁的边缘。你有点担心吗？嗯，也许吧。嗯，格雷格没打算失去他们。他不想失去仓库里的任何人。但他还告诉我，他不想雇一个你在节目中从未见过的新人，只是为了解雇他们。
He felt like those stakes would feel very manufactured. So he turned to our two background actors, Creed and Devin. Creed and Devin, yeah. And he was like, well, these guys are very well established on the show at this point. And this is where I'd like to know what happened because I know the end of this story, which is that Greg found out that Devin had a theater contract coming up that he was going to go on on tour with a play. And so that- That's what Devin said.
他觉得那样的赌注会感觉非常人为。所以他转向了我们的两名背景演员，克里德和德文（Devin）。克里德和德文，是的。他当时想，嗯，这些家伙在这一点上在节目中已经非常稳固了。这就是我想知道发生了什么的地方，因为我知道这个故事的结局，那就是格雷格发现德文有一个即将到来的戏剧合同，他要随剧团去巡演。所以那个——那是德文说的。
Yeah. At the time though, they told us, one of you guys are gonna have to go. Oh man, geez. And we went, but we don't know yet. We're just gonna do that. We're gonna shoot you both. We're gonna see how it works out.
是的。不过当时，他们告诉我们，你们其中一个人得走。哦天哪，天哪。我们去了，但我们还不知道。我们只是要那样做。我们要拍你们两个。我们要看看结果如何。
Oh my God. Wait, they're gonna shoot the scene two ways? They know that we're gonna shoot the thing because they could have gone back and changed it, I'm sure. Oh, oh, cause Michael could have said, you know what, I said it was Creed and it's Creed. You can't change my mind. But it was gonna be one of us.
哦天哪。等等，他们要用两种方式拍那场戏？他们知道我们要拍那件事，因为他们肯定可以回去修改它。哦，哦，因为迈克尔本来可以说，你知道吗，我说过是克里德，那就是克里德。你不能改变我的想法。但本来会是我们其中之一。
They said it was gonna be one of us. And I remember being a little nervous. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. And Devin and I were friends. We'd become friends by this time. Well, sure. And by the way, you know, on the finale, jumping ahead a lot.
他们说本来会是我们其中之一。我记得我有点紧张。是的。是的，是的。德文和我当时是朋友。到这个时候我们已经成为朋友了。嗯，当然。顺便说一下，你知道，在结局里，跳跃了很多。
I don't know if I could kind of jump ahead. You can. You can. When Greg brought me to the office to find out what I wanted to do for the Kree character, I said, well, one thing I'd like to do is sing the song. Sing my song, but I also think we should have Devin back on the show. Oh, great. That's nice. We get together sometimes, you know, and have coffee and stuff like that.
我不知道我能不能跳跃。你可以。你可以。当格雷格带我到办公室想看看我想为克里德这个角色做什么时，我说，嗯，有一件事我想做，那就是唱歌。唱我的歌，但我也认为我们应该让德文回到节目中。哦，太好了。那很好。我们有时会聚在一起，你知道，喝咖啡什么的。
I was feeling nervous because I was feeling bad that I might have to go, but also that Devin might have to go too. So it was mixed blessings and all that stuff. All right. Fast fact number two. This is the first time we see Pam's hair down instead of her usual half up half down hair clip. That to me is so important. Oh, well then Creed, you're going to love some of my note cards if that's important. Buckle in.
我当时感到紧张，因为我感到难过，我可能不得不走，但也难过德文也可能不得不走。所以这是喜忧参半。好吧。快速事实二。这是我们第一次看到帕姆（Pam）的头发放下来，而不是她通常的半扎发夹。对我来说这太重要了。哦，好吧，克里德，如果这很重要的话，你会喜欢我的一些笔记卡的。系好安全带。
But this was a huge deal. Kim Ferry, our hairstylist and me and, and Paul Feig, we all had a meeting about Pam's hair and if we could let her hair down. And it was, I mean, it must have been 30 minutes we talked about it. There was a lot of concern that she might look too pretty with her hair down. And I can't remember how we got permission. Kim was delighted. I mean, Kim had been putting my hair in a hair clip now
但这可是件大事。金·费里（Kim Ferry），我们的发型师，还有我和保罗·费格，我们都开了一个关于帕姆头发的会议，看能不能让她把头发放下来。我的意思是，我们肯定讨论了30分钟。有很多担心，她把头发放下来可能看起来太漂亮了。我不记得我们是怎么得到许可的。金很高兴。我的意思是，金已经把我的头发用发夹夹起来了
for like 12 episodes or something. She was so thrilled to be able to scrunch it. Do something different. Anything, anything different. And it was kind of a big deal. So. Well, they were playing down both of your beauties all the time with the way they dressed you
大概12集左右了。她非常激动能把它弄蓬松。做点不同的事情。任何事情，任何不同的事情。这算是一件大事。所以。嗯，他们一直通过给你们穿的衣服来淡化你们的美貌
and put you in scruff. That's right. Did everyone hear that? Did you fight? Oh, that's true. Creen says they played down's true. That's true. It says they played down our beauty. That is true.
并让你们穿得邋遢。没错。大家都听到了吗？你们打架了吗？哦，那是真的。克里德说他们淡化了……是真的。那是真的。它说他们淡化了我们的美貌。那是真的。
Toward the end, did you guys lobby for, come on, just let us show a little bit of, you know. I remember really wanting lip gloss. I was- Yeah, something like that. So what's funny to me is that that was a 30 minute meeting about your hair. Meanwhile, I go to hair and makeup
在最后，你们有没有游说，拜托，让我们展示一点点，你知道。我记得真的很想要唇彩。我当时——是的，类似那样。所以对我来说有趣的是，那是一个关于你头发的30分钟会议。同时，我去化妆和发型
and they put on full, enormous, purple, fake eyelashes on me. If you look at me as this cat, I have big purple eyelashes. They were so huge, I had a hard time even navigating them. When I watched the episode, I look a little sleepy. I think it's because I couldn't open my eyes. No meeting. No meeting. I was like, are you sure?
他们给我戴上了全套、巨大的、紫色的假睫毛。如果你看我扮演这只猫，我有巨大的紫色睫毛。它们太大了，我甚至很难驾驭它们。当我看那一集时，我看起来有点困。我想是因为我睁不开眼睛。没有会议。没有会议。我当时想，你确定吗？
They just put them on me. And then one of the writers walked up to me, I can't remember who, and was like, are you sure? They just put them on me. And then one of the writers walked up to me, I can't remember who, and was like, do you have purple? It's probably Mindy. She was like, do you have purple lashes on? She might've been jealous. Yeah. Yeah, she wanted them.
他们只是把它们戴在我身上。然后其中一个编剧走到我面前，我不记得是谁了，就像是，你确定吗？他们只是把它们戴在我身上。然后其中一个编剧走到我面前，我不记得是谁了，就像是，你有紫色吗？可能是明迪（Mindy）。她当时想，你戴着紫色睫毛吗？她可能嫉妒了。是的。是的，她想要它们。
She would want those purple lashes. No one said anything. Why is Angela Martin putting on purple fake eyelashes? Everyone was too busy meeting about my hair. Yeah. Yes, yes. All right, fast fact number three. Creed, too busy meeting about my hair. Yeah. Yes, yes. All right, fast fact number three. Creed, I don't know if you remember this, Angela, I think maybe you do.
她会想要那些紫色睫毛。没人说什么。为什么安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）要戴紫色假睫毛？每个人都忙着开关于我头发的会议。是的，是的。好吧，快速事实三。克里德，忙着开关于我头发的会议。是的，是的。好吧，快速事实三。克里德，我不知道你是否记得这个，安吉拉，我想也许你记得。
The week we shot the Halloween episode, Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant visited one day. I know this because I have a photograph with them- In your cat outfit? In my cat outfit, and Jim is three hole punch Jim, but you can't really see the holes cause he's got his arm around someone. So it's a whole picture of our producers and Ricky and Steven and me and John. And I am the only person wearing a costume.
我们拍摄《万圣节》那一周，瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特（Stephen Merchant）有一天来访。我知道这一点，因为我和他们有一张照片——穿着你的猫装？穿着我的猫装，吉姆是三孔打孔吉姆，但你看不出那些孔，因为他搂着某人。所以这是一张我们的制片人、瑞奇、斯蒂芬、我和约翰的照片。我是唯一一个穿着服装的人。
I like to imagine that they came to see me in a play where I played a cat or something. Your one act play? Cause we look like we're standing backstage. And you were in the cast, yeah. You're the only one in a costume. This is how I know this because I only have two pictures of myself with Ricky and Steven and one of them is me in a cat costume.
我喜欢想象他们来看我演的一部戏，我在里面演一只猫什么的。你的独幕剧？因为我们看起来像是站在后台。而你是演员阵容里的，是的。你是唯一一个穿着服装的人。这就是我为什么知道这一点，因为我只有两张我和瑞奇、斯蒂芬的照片，其中一张是我穿着猫装。
I remember that they were there because my ears still hurt from that high castralto of Ricky Gervais. The laugh. I've ricked your face. The laugh. That's such a good impression. He laughed. He laughed at everything. He was so good natured. He laughed at it.
我记得他们在那里，因为我的耳朵仍然因为瑞奇·热维斯那高亢的假声而疼痛。笑声。我瑞奇·热维斯了。笑声。那真是个很好的模仿。他笑了。他什么都笑。他脾气很好。他笑了。
He typed some coffee. Oh, by the way, ladies and gentlemen, he is the sweetest man and just a joy. All right. Those are my fast facts. That's our summary. Maybe we should... Do we need that bathroom break? Let's do a bathroom break. Let's do a bathroom break.
他喝了一些咖啡。哦，顺便说一下，女士们先生们，他是最可爱的人，简直是一种乐趣。好吧。那些是我的快速事实。那是我们的总结。也许我们应该……我们需要那个上厕所的时间吗？我们去上个厕所吧。我们去上个厕所吧。
I could use one. By the way, I just want to say I just love these fast facts. Oh, well then if you love the fast facts, get ready for the note cards, Creed. Oh my God, I can't wait. Be still my throbbing heart. Okay. It sounded a little weird when you said it like that.
我可以用一下。顺便说一下，我只想说我真的很喜欢这些快速事实。哦，好吧，如果你喜欢快速事实，准备好迎接笔记卡吧，克里德。天哪，我等不及了。让我的心跳停止吧。好吧。你那样说的时候听起来有点奇怪。
It started to be weird and then I drifted away. Okay. Go back, go to the bathroom. All right. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Every January is a time when I feel like we all reflect. You know, you can really do it any time of the year, but I think, you know, you do feel that reset.
它开始变得奇怪，然后我走神了。好吧。回去，去上厕所。好吧。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。每年的每一月都是我觉得我们都在反思的时候。你知道，你真的可以在一年中的任何时候做，但我认为，你知道，你确实感受到了那种重置。
You do. It's like you have 365 blank pages ahead of you, just waiting to be filled, and you can decide how to do that. I'm so poetic, Angela. Oh, really? Thanks. 365 blank pages. Well, I might've had some help. All right.
你确实感受到了。就像你有365页空白页在你面前，等着被填满，你可以决定如何做。我太有诗意了，安吉拉。哦，真的吗？谢谢。365页空白页。嗯，我可能得到了一些帮助。好吧。
Well, I'm going with your book metaphor. Okay. You could think of therapy as your editorial partner, helping you to write these new chapters and create the meaningful story that you deserve to live. How do you like that? I really like it a lot. BetterHelp is fully online and making therapy affordable and convenient serving over 5 million people worldwide. It has a diverse network of more than
嗯，我同意你的书的隐喻。好的。你可以把心理治疗看作你的编辑伙伴，帮助你写这些新章节，创造你值得拥有的有意义的故事。你觉得怎么样？我真的很喜欢它。BetterHelp完全在线，让心理治疗变得负担得起且方便，为全球超过500万人提供服务。它拥有一个多元化的网络，拥有超过
30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. And you can switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Write your story with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. Say hello to Tim Selects, Tim's everyday value menu. Enjoy the new spinach and Office Ladies. There's another great city that starts with a T. Tampa, Florida. Fly to Tampa on Porter Airlines to see why it's so te-rific. On your way there, relax with free beer, wine, and snacks, free fast-streaming Wi-Fi, and no middle seats. You've never flown to Florida like this before, so you'll land in Tampa ready to explore. Visit flyporter.com and actually enjoy economy.
30,000名拥有广泛专业领域的认证治疗师。你可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。用BetterHelp写下你的故事。今天访问betterhelp.com/office ladies，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp.com/office ladies。向Tim Selects问好，Tim的日常超值菜单。享受新的菠菜和Office Ladies。还有另一个以T开头的伟大城市。佛罗里达州坦帕市。乘坐波特航空（Porter Airlines）飞往坦帕，看看为什么它如此棒。在去那里的路上，享受免费啤酒、葡萄酒和零食，免费的高速流媒体Wi-Fi，并且没有中间座位。你以前从未这样飞往佛罗里达，所以你降落在坦帕时已经准备好去探索了。访问flyporter.com，真正享受经济舱。
All right, let's get into some note cards. Can we? Note cards. Yes. All right. Let's get into the episode. Let's do it. I have a note card from the cold open. Oh, what is the cold open of this episode? Okay, so the cold open is you say that Jan called
好吧，让我们进入一些笔记卡。我们可以吗？笔记卡。是的。好吧。让我们进入这一集。让我们开始吧。我有一张来自冷开场的笔记卡。哦，这一集的冷开场是什么？好的，所以冷开场是你说是简（Jan）打来的
and he's like, oh, and Michael has to go in because he knows he has to fire someone. Right. And so he calls Jan and her assistant, Sherry, answers the phone. Yes. And Sherry has so much good sass. She's like, okay, well, who are you gonna fire?
他说，哦，迈克尔必须进去，因为他知道他必须解雇某人。对。所以他给简打电话，她的助理雪莉（Sherry）接了电话。是的。雪莉非常有那种傲慢劲。她说，好吧，你要解雇谁？
And he goes, well, I'm not really sure. And she's like, we just need the name. Jan needs the name. Jan needs the name. And then he's like, who would you fire? And she's like, just give me the name. And then, and then he thinks he's hung up and he's like, I'd like to fire you. And she goes, still here. Right? He's like, I wish I could fire Sherry. Sherry. I mean, I want to know who Sherry is. Who is Sherry? Yes, I thought the same thing. So the first thing I did, I went to IMDb, Internet Movie Database. I did too.
他说，嗯，我不太确定。她说，我们只需要名字。简需要名字。简需要名字。然后他说，你会解雇谁？她说，给我名字。然后，然后他以为他挂断了，他说，我想解雇你。她说，还在呢。对吧？他说，我希望我能解雇雪莉。雪莉。我的意思是，我想知道雪莉是谁。雪莉是谁？是的，我也想到了同样的事情。所以我做的第一件事，我去了IMDb，互联网电影资料库。我也去了。
I looked up this episode, uncredited. Uncredited. Who is Sherry? Who is Sherry? I reached out to Dave Rogers. He was the editor for this episode. You guys, he knows everything about the office. He didn't know.
我查了这一集，未署名。未署名。雪莉是谁？雪莉是谁？我联系了戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）。他是这一集的剪辑师。伙计们，他知道关于《办公室》的一切。他不知道。
That is saying something, because he is like the walking Bible of the show. He's an encyclopedic memory cat. No one knows. Listen to what Dave did. Dave reached out to Alison Jones, our casting director, who went to her storage facility. Oh my Lord.
这说明了一些问题，因为他就像节目的活字典。他是一只百科全书式的记忆猫。没人知道。听听戴夫做了什么。戴夫联系了艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones），我们的选角导演，她去了她的存储设施。哦，我的天哪。
Found the contracts for this episode, looked it up. Wow. Allison, thank you. Oh my gosh, Allison, you're like an episode of the Pelican Brief. It is. An episode. The movie. CSI The Office.
找到了这一集的合同，查了一下。哇。艾莉森，谢谢。哦，天哪，艾莉森，你就像《鹈鹕暗杀令》（The Pelican Brief）的一集。确实。一集。电影。CSI《办公室》。
You're like CSI The Office. It is Lisa Malone. Okay. And by the way, this was shot on September 13th, 2005. Wow. Yeah. Well, Lisa, you were fantastic as Sheri. You killed it.
你就像CSI《办公室》。是丽莎·马龙（Lisa Malone）。好的。顺便说一下，这是在2005年9月13日拍摄的。哇。是的。嗯，丽莎，你作为雪莉太棒了。你演得太好了。
You killed it as Sheri. You killed it. You killed it as Sheri. Oh man, and Allison, thank you. Thank you for being our CSI, the office. I wanna go back, Angela, because I have a note that precedes your note card. Is it at five seconds?
你演雪莉演得太好了。你演得太好了。你演雪莉演得太好了。哦，伙计，还有艾莉森，谢谢。谢谢你成为我们的CSI《办公室》。我想回去，安吉拉，因为我有一条笔记在你的笔记卡之前。是在五秒钟吗？
Is it the shot of Devon and Creed at their desks? The establishing shot, yes. I noticed it too. The second shot of this episode is Creed and Devon at their desks. The establishing shot. Yes, yes. I noticed it too. The second shot of this episode is Creed and Devon at their desks. I have to imagine this was not an accident that they wanted to drive home Devon and Creed since we know that one of you.
是德文和克里德在桌子前的镜头吗？建立镜头，是的。我也注意到了。这一集的第二个镜头是克里德和德文在他们的桌子前。建立镜头。是的，是的。我也注意到了。这一集的第二个镜头是克里德和德文在他们的桌子前。我不得不想象这不是偶然的，他们想强调德文和克里德，因为我们知道你们其中一个。
It was well placed. Yes, yes. It's Phyllis putting on makeup and then it goes to Devon and Creed at their desks. Well, the scene with Michael and Pam, do you guys remember how he's wearing the second head? Yes. Yes.
位置安排得很好。是的，是的。菲利斯在化妆，然后镜头转到德文和克里德在办公桌前。对了，迈克尔和帕姆的那场戏，你们还记得他戴着第二个头吗？记得。是的。
Oh, I have a card. Pam goes in his office and he tells her that he needs to fire someone, and then he sort of implies maybe it could be her. Oh, I have two cards from this scene. And so Pam decides to quickly start flattering him. She pivots hard. About his costume and then she just gets out of the room
哦，我有一张卡片。帕姆走进他的办公室，他告诉她他需要解雇一个人，然后他暗示那个人可能是她。哦，我这场戏有两张卡片。于是帕姆决定赶紧开始奉承他。她迅速转变了态度。谈论他的服装，然后她就尽快离开了房间。
as quickly as possible. I could not get through that scene. Listen, Steve is funny enough on his own, but Steve with that extra Steve on his shoulder, it was too much and it wobbled in a sort of weird way. He was wobbling it on purpose. He loved it. He loved wobbling that thing. He loved it.
我没法看完那场戏。听着，史蒂夫本身就够好笑了，但肩膀上多了一个史蒂夫的史蒂夫，这太夸张了，而且它晃动的方式很奇怪。他是故意晃动的。他很喜欢。他很喜欢晃那个东西。他很喜欢。
Anytime you give him a little cat or... That's what she said. Come on, guys. That was a great... That's what she said. Come on. He loves wobbling things. He loved wobbling that thing.
每当你给他一只小猫或者……这就是她说的。拜托，伙计们。那是一个很棒的……这就是她说的。拜托。他喜欢晃动东西。他很喜欢晃那个东西。
Oh, that's what she said. Hey! We got it back. We got it back. Creed, what did I write? At three minutes, 12 seconds. Oh my God, Pam is diabolical. Her turn to flattery when she realizes Michael
哦，这就是她说的。嘿！我们找回来了。我们找回来了。克里德，我写了什么？在3分12秒。天哪，帕姆真是太邪恶了。当她意识到迈克尔要解雇她时，她转而奉承他。
would fire her. Wow. Diabolical. Diabolical. I'm seeing a real devious streak in Pam. I want to just comment, if I may. Please. The brilliance of Steve Carell,
哇。邪恶。邪恶。我在帕姆身上看到了真正的狡诈。如果可以的话，我想发表一下评论。请讲。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的才华，
the pain and the anguish in his face when he's getting ready to fire someone. You can just see it there. He's just dying. He's absolutely dying. He's not acting. He's like, to me, he looked like a man just suffering, suffering from the pre-eminent death.
当他准备解雇某人时，他脸上的痛苦和煎熬。你一眼就能看出来。他简直要死了。他绝对要死了。他不是在演戏。对我来说，他看起来就像一个正在受苦的人，因即将到来的死亡而受苦。
It's interesting you bring that up, Creed, because we've talked a lot about how Michael wants to be popular. He wants to be friends with people. He wants to be the life of the party. But I think this episode goes beyond that. That it isn't just that he knows that it's gonna be, he's gonna not be well liked by the person he fires. I think it really like,
克里德，你提到这一点很有趣，因为我们谈论了很多关于迈克尔如何想要受欢迎。他想和大家做朋友。他想成为派对的灵魂人物。但我认为这一集超越了这一点。不仅仅是因为他知道他不会被他解雇的人喜欢。我认为这真的，
I think it touches on something. He really doesn't want to hurt someone else. Yep, that's exactly right. So it's deeper than that, just unpopularity thing. I was moved by his performance in that. Yeah. Same. I mean, yeah, he crushed it. I get more pictures at Halloween of Pam as a cat and Jim as three hole punch. I think that is the most popular Halloween costume that I get sent to me. I get Angela Martin in an Argyle sweater, with a turtleneck and a headband holding a stuffed animal cat next to some guy in a mustard shirt
我认为这触及了一些东西。他真的不想伤害别人。是的，完全正确。所以这比不受欢迎这件事更深层。他的表演让我很感动。是的。我也是。我的意思是，是的，他演得太棒了。万圣节时，我收到更多帕姆扮成猫和吉姆扮成三孔活页纸的照片。我认为这是我收到的最受欢迎的万圣节服装。我收到安吉拉·马丁穿着菱形花纹毛衣，戴着高领毛衣和发带，抱着一只毛绒猫，旁边站着一个穿着芥末色衬衫、打着领带、头发中分的男人。
with a tie and his hair parted down the middle. What about you, Creed? I get the Joker. The Joker. When I walk in as the Joker. And then when Brian comes, damn it, Creed, and he hip checks you. Oh, that's a later episode. Yeah, that when you guys are both dressed in the same costume. He almost knocks you over. Oh yeah. I howl every time I see it.
你呢，克里德？我扮成小丑。小丑。当我扮成小丑走进来时。然后当布莱恩来的时候，该死，克里德，他用臀部撞你。哦，那是后面的一集。是的，当你们俩都穿同样的服装时。他差点把你撞倒。哦，是的。每次看到我都笑得打滚。
That's a recurring thing. It's brilliant, brilliant. Angela, I wanna talk to you about your costume. Please. Okay, Michael comes over to accounting. You're dressed as a cat. There's three cats. Phyllis is a cat. Phyllis.
这是一个反复出现的梗。太棒了，太棒了。安吉拉，我想和你谈谈你的服装。请讲。好的，迈克尔来到会计部。你打扮成一只猫。有三只猫。菲利斯是一只猫。菲利斯。
I'm a cat, you're a cat. Yes, actually we could do really quickly the rundown of costumes. Kelly is Dorothy. Phyllis, Pam and Angela are cats. Dwight is a Sith Lord. Kevin is the Dunder Mifflin superhero. Creed is a vampire.
我是猫，你是猫。是的，其实我们可以很快过一遍服装。凯利是多萝西。菲利斯、帕姆和安吉拉是猫。德怀特是西斯尊主。凯文是邓德·米夫林超级英雄。克里德是吸血鬼。
Oscar is a lady. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if he's a character lady or just a lady. I think he's a lady. He's just a lady. Jim is three hole punch. Jim, Stanley, no costume. Ryan the temp, no costume.
奥斯卡是一位女士。是的。是的。我不知道他是一个角色女士还是仅仅是一位女士。我想他是一位女士。他就是一位女士。吉姆是三孔活页纸。吉姆，斯坦利，没有服装。瑞安实习生，没有服装。
And of course, Michael has the two heads. And Devin was a tramp. And Devin was a hobo. Hobo, yeah. Angela, why does your cat only have two lines for whiskers and not three? Jenna, I don't know. Why does my cat
当然，迈克尔有两个头。德文是流浪汉。德文是流浪汉。流浪汉，是的。安吉拉，为什么你的猫胡须只有两道而不是三道？珍娜，我不知道。为什么我的猫
have purple fake eyelashes? Why does your cat have weird cat ears? I mean, I just wanna say that as the resident cat lady of the office, I think you have the worst cat costume. Why do I have a fuzzy white skirt? Why? With a giant tail that was almost impossible to sit in. It was so, and the skirt didn't quite fit me
有紫色的假睫毛？为什么你的猫有奇怪的猫耳朵？我的意思是，我只想说，作为办公室的常驻猫女，我认为你的猫服装是最差的。为什么我有一条毛茸茸的白裙子？为什么？还有一条巨大的尾巴，坐着几乎不可能。它太……而且裙子不太合身，
and it kept like heading south. I had to keep like grabbing it and yanking it up. It almost ruined the whole episode, that whole captain. I think now there was such a big meeting about your hair that my cat costume was just like, eh, I just put this on her. But you ended up wearing that costume like two more times. For years. And it's the worst one. It really is. I have a vague memory, a very, very vague memory of being in makeup and having them discuss how they were going to differentiate the three different cats. And it was decided that Phyllis and I would have three whiskers on each cheek and you would only have two. My cat was maimed. I feel like that happened.
它一直往下滑。我不得不一直抓着它往上提。那整场戏差点毁了整集。我想现在关于你的头发有那么大的会议，以至于我的猫服装就像是，呃，我只是给她穿上了这个。但你最终又穿了那套服装两次。好几年了。而且它是最差的一套。确实是。我有一个模糊的记忆，非常非常模糊的记忆，关于在化妆间，他们讨论如何区分这三只不同的猫。最后决定菲利斯和我会每边脸有三根胡须，而你只有两根。我的猫被毁容了。我觉得是这样发生的。
I don't know if we can ask Laverne. Laverne was our makeup artist. I don't know. I don't know. But I mean, right? I just think you had... You were smaller. You didn't deserve three. They decided to give me less. I have to... While we're talking about this scene in accounting, I have to point out that we don't often, our camera guys didn't often do like a full character slow pan, you know? And they do such a hilarious one. They start at Kevin's feet and they go all the way to his head while he's filing to get him in full red leotard.
我不知道我们能不能问拉弗恩。拉弗恩是我们的化妆师。我不知道。我不知道。但我的意思是，对吧？我只是觉得你……你比较小。你不配有三根。他们决定给我少一点。我必须……在我们谈论会计部这场戏时，我必须指出，我们不常……我们的摄像师不常做那种完整的角色慢镜头平移，你知道吗？他们做了一个非常搞笑的。他们从凯文的脚开始，一直平移到他的头，当时他正在归档，让他全身穿着红色紧身衣。
With his socks all miss bulging and brung areas. Oh my gosh. It's great. It's great. There's a great slow pan of Kevin. We should say we loved dressing up in these Halloween costumes because our outfits normally were pretty boilerplate. It was almost like we wore uniforms in a way.
他的袜子全都鼓鼓囊囊的。天哪。太棒了。太棒了。凯文有一个很棒的慢镜头平移。我们应该说我们喜欢穿这些万圣节服装，因为我们的日常服装通常很刻板。某种程度上就像我们穿制服一样。
And our wardrobe people loved, the wardrobe crew loved getting to dress us because it was just like gray turtleneck. Angela, give us a note card. All right, at five minutes, 23 seconds. Creed, this is a runner. This is a reference to a runner, but this is a really big deal.
我们的服装组喜欢，服装组喜欢给我们穿衣服，因为那就像灰色高领毛衣。安吉拉，给我们一张笔记卡。好的，在5分23秒。克里德，这是一个反复出现的梗。这是对一个梗的引用，但这真的是一件大事。
What? Kelly has braided like pigtails. Oh! Her hair is down. Her hair is down. Oh hair is down her hair is down Oh my it's not in a bad member Mindy had a bun for like the whole first season and then about I guess it was like A twist a French twist. I think I mean she looked her character really changes her look and then she starts having her hair down She gets a little sassy, but this has been a big thing. We've been wondering when did they change her hair? This is the beginning. I see, I don't think this counts
什么？凯利扎了辫子。哦！她的头发放下来了。她的头发放下来了。哦，头发放下来了，她的头发放下来了。天哪，这并不坏。我记得明迪在第一季大部分时间里都梳着发髻，然后大约……我想那是一个扭转，法式扭转。我的意思是，她的角色确实改变了造型，然后她开始把头发放下来。她变得有点俏皮，但这一直是一件大事。我们一直在想，他们什么时候改变了她的发型？这是开始。你看，我不认为这算数，
because it's a Halloween costume. What? Yeah, I'm sorry to say. No, I agree. I have to say I'm with Jenna. Thank you. It doesn't count. Well, I don't know if I like you here, Kree.
因为这是万圣节服装。什么？是的，很抱歉这么说。不，我同意。我必须说我和珍娜站在一起。谢谢。这不算数。好吧，我不知道我是否还喜欢你，克里德。
All of a sudden I have someone. Oh, well. To veto. I'm sorry. Two against one. Oh, fart. Well, I got pretty excited because her hair was down. But it was a costume though. It wasn't a repudate in character thing.
突然我有人了。哦，好吧。来否决。抱歉。二对一。哦，该死。好吧，我很兴奋，因为她的头发放下来了。但这毕竟是服装。这不是一个角色本身的改变。
See? That's what I'm saying. Am I talking to Jenna or Creed? It doesn't apply. I don't know anymore. It doesn't apply. All right. You know the scene where Pam and Jim set up a resume for Dwight to get a job someplace
看吧？这就是我说的。我在和珍娜说话还是和克里德说话？这不适用。我不知道了。这不适用。好吧。你知道帕姆和吉姆为德怀特准备简历去别处找工作的那场戏吗？
else? I have a fan question about that. RCJH asked, what were you typing on the computer when you and Jim were working on Dwight's resume? I was typing what we were saying. Of course you were, Jenna. Of course you were. Because you're so method. I was very method. You're like, I am a responsible person. You would type out your lines around the computer while you were doing it?
我有一个粉丝问题。RCJH问，当你和吉姆在做德怀特的简历时，你在电脑上打什么？我在打我们正在说的话。你当然在打，珍娜。你当然在打。因为你太入戏了。我非常入戏。你就像，我是一个负责任的人。你在做的时候会把台词打在电脑上吗？
Yeah, because Jim would say, like, I would say, what should we say here? And then he would say what we should say, and I would type it. And I see, here's the like, I would say, what should we say here? And then he would say what we should say, and I would type it. And I see, here's the thing, I'm very proud of my typing skills. Oh, we know, we know. Yeah. Creed, do we know or do we know?
是的，因为吉姆会说，比如，我会说，我们在这里应该说什么？然后他会说我们应该说什么，我就打出来。你看，这就是……我会说，我们在这里应该说什么？然后他会说我们应该说什么，我就打出来。你看，这就是重点，我为我的打字技术感到自豪。哦，我们知道，我们知道。是的。克里德，我们知道还是我们知道？
We really know. You guys? Now I'm back on your side, Angela. Thank you, Creed. Just talk about, you know. Is this how it feels? Yes. This is how it feels, Angela.
我们真的知道。你们？现在我回到你这边了，安吉拉。谢谢，克里德。只是谈谈，你知道。这就是这种感觉吗？是的。这就是这种感觉，安吉拉。
We know. When you walk in this thing with your fingers, you'd be sitting there, we'd be talking about stuff in a craster and your fingers would be going like you're typing. Oh, now that is not true. It was too much. It was too much.
我们知道。当你用手指走进来时，你会坐在那里，我们会在谈论事情，你的手指会像在打字一样动。哦，那不是真的。太夸张了。太夸张了。
Tone it down. And then you would tell us about your typing speed and your level of accuracy. Well, you should know I was typing her actual lines because I could. Well, I think that's pretty great though. Because she could and I can and I will. Well, I think that's pretty great though. Because I can. Because she could and I can and I will. And you're fast too. She's very fast.
收敛一点。然后你会告诉我们你的打字速度和准确率。好吧，你应该知道我在打她真实的台词，因为我能做到。好吧，我觉得那很棒。因为她能做到，我也能，而且我会做。好吧，我觉得那很棒。因为我能。因为她能做到，我也能，而且我会做。而且你打字也很快。她非常快。
Anyway. Michael's scene with Dwight when he calls Dwight into his office and he tells Dwight that he has to fire someone and Dwight starts naming all the people he should fire. But then Michael implies maybe it should be Dwight. And then Michael's second head starts talking to Dwight. Do you remember Steve and Rain laughing during that scene? Because I do. I remember they could not get through that scene.
总之。迈克尔和德怀特的那场戏，他把德怀特叫进办公室，告诉德怀特他必须解雇某人，德怀特开始列举所有他应该解雇的人。但随后迈克尔暗示也许应该是德怀特。然后迈克尔的第二个头开始和德怀特说话。你记得史蒂夫和雷恩在那场戏中笑场了吗？因为我记得。我记得他们没法演完那场戏。
I'm sitting out at reception in the background and they were cracking themselves up in there. Rain was literally doubling over because he was like kind of leaning forward and he would just kind of collapse into himself. He was laughing so hard. There must be deleted scenes of that scene. Oh man, I would love to see those.
我坐在背景里的接待处，他们在里面笑得前仰后合。雷恩简直弯下了腰，因为他有点向前倾，然后他会整个人塌下去。他笑得太厉害了。那场戏一定有删减片段。哦天哪，我很想看看那些。
I would love to see that. That is a funny scene. Well, Paul Feig called in when we did Office Olympics and he said one of the things he loved about directing episodes of our shows is that you could really find a shot that was cool and you would have the support of Greg to just kind of go with it. And he sort of found that shot where Dwight as
我很想看看。那是一场有趣的戏。好吧，保罗·费格在我们做办公室奥运会时打来电话，他说他喜欢执导我们剧集的原因之一是，你可以真正找到一个很酷的镜头，并且会得到格雷格的支持去尝试。他找到了那个镜头，德怀特作为
the Sith Lord has his hood kind of like, it looks like it's straight out of the movie. It does. You know? Yes. And they just loved that. They shot from the side, right? Yeah, shot from the side. And they sort of just found that and went with it. And Greg was totally supportive of it. And Paul was talking about like how fun that was to have
西斯尊主，他的兜帽看起来就像直接从电影里出来的一样。确实。你知道吗？是的。他们就是喜欢那样。他们从侧面拍摄，对吧？是的，从侧面拍摄。他们只是发现了那个角度并坚持了下来。格雷格完全支持。保罗谈到拥有那种创作自由并找到那些小亮点是多么有趣。
that creative freedom and find those little nuggets. And it's so cool looking. We had a lot of shots like that. They're just more the cookie cutter or a stereotype, you know, sitcom stuff. And we get interesting shots. Yeah. Because the cameramen were so great. And something that we haven't talked about on the show yet is the idea of actor marks. So usually on a television show, so that they can get these shots,
而且看起来太酷了。我们有很多那样的镜头。它们不仅仅是那种千篇一律的、刻板的、情景喜剧的东西。我们得到了有趣的镜头。是的。因为摄像师太棒了。我们还没在节目中谈论过的一件事是演员标记的概念。通常在电视节目中，为了得到这些镜头，
they put a little piece of tape on the ground. And if you, for example, if Jim had to walk up to Pam's desk, there would be a little mark on the ground and he would have to stand exactly on that mark. And it's really hard to do. I mean, do you guys find it hard to do? I'm always, I feel like I'm always looking down for the tape and then I get to my spot
他们会在地上贴一小块胶带。如果你，比如，如果吉姆必须走到帕姆的桌子前，地上会有一个小标记，他必须准确地站在那个标记上。这真的很难做到。我的意思是，你们觉得很难吗？我总是觉得我一直在低头找胶带，然后我到了我的位置，
and I look up. It's like a hard thing to manage. Well, on our show, we did not have that. They would just let us wander. They would say, just walk up in this general area and the camera will find you. It was so loosey goosey, so amazing. Didn't you say you were in a band called Lucy Goosey? I was in a band called Lucy Goosey. What? I was in a band with Peter White, who used to play with Al Stewart,
我就抬头。这很难管理。好吧，在我们的节目中，我们没有那样做。他们只是让我们随意走动。他们会说，就在这个大致区域走动，摄像机会找到你。这太随意了，太神奇了。你不是说你在一个叫“露西·古西”的乐队吗？我确实在一个叫“露西·古西”的乐队。什么？我和彼得·怀特在一个乐队，他曾经和阿尔·斯图尔特一起演奏，
and he probably still does. We had a band with Dave Camp on sax, and I remember we played the rap party for this movie I did with, worked on with Bo Bridges at the beach house, at Lloyd Bridges' house, Lucy Goosey. We played out there and they were dancing out there like Annette Funicello in the surf and stuff. Oh my gosh.
他可能现在还在演奏。我们有一个乐队，戴夫·坎普吹萨克斯，我记得我们在我做的一部电影的杀青派对上演奏，那是和博·布里奇斯一起工作的，在海滩别墅，在劳埃德·布里奇斯的房子里，露西·古西。我们在那里演奏，他们像安妮特·弗尼塞洛一样在冲浪中跳舞。哦天哪。
Lucy Goosey. Creed, we just need you to sit here and tell us about all your stories. Creed, you have literally the most interesting life. I have a fan question for you. I'm a fascinating character. You are. And humble too. This is a fan question from Todd Myers and this feels like a good place to ask it. Who is the biggest rock star you ever partied with during your touring days?
露西·古西。克里德，我们只需要你坐在这里给我们讲你所有的故事。克里德，你的生活简直是最有趣的。我有一个粉丝问题要问你。我是一个迷人的角色。你是。而且很谦虚。这是一个来自托德·迈尔斯的粉丝问题，我觉得现在问这个问题很合适。你在巡演期间一起聚会过的最大的摇滚明星是谁？
Oh. Wow. Partied with? It maybe doesn't have to be the biggest. It could just, what's the most interesting? Yeah. I lived for a while at the Camrose Highland Estates, and Linda Ronstadt was there, Laura Nero was there,
哦。哇。一起聚会？也许不一定是最大的。可以是，什么是最有趣的？是的。我有一段时间住在卡姆罗斯高地庄园，琳达·朗斯塔特在那里，劳拉·尼罗在那里，
Jackson Brown used to, there was a lot of people playing at this place and lived there and they would play their instruments. You hear the instruments going around the Cameroon Highland Estates, and Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers was there and one night Butch came over. Wait, wait, wait, I'm so sorry. You all lived together?
杰克逊·布朗过去常……很多人在这个地方演奏并住在这里，他们会演奏他们的乐器。你听到乐器在卡姆罗斯高地庄园周围响起，奥尔曼兄弟乐队的布奇·特拉克斯也在那里，有一天晚上布奇过来了。等等，等等，我很抱歉。你们都住在一起吗？
No, we lived at the States in little bungalows. You could rent these bungalows at the Cameros Highland States. Now it's been fixed up a little bit. It's right next to the Veterans of War and War place, I think, right on Highland Boulevard, right on Highland Boulevard. Right off to get off the freeways, right there. And like a lot of artists live there.
不，我们住在庄园里的小平房里。你可以租这些平房。现在它被稍微修缮了一下。它就在退伍军人纪念馆旁边，我想，就在高地大道上，就在高地大道上。就在高速公路出口旁边，就在那里。很多艺术家住在那儿。
A lot of artists were living there. So Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers came over one night, and Griffin from The Bread, and Jesse Ed Davis, who used to play with John Lennon, came over one night and we jammed, we jammed for hours and hours and hours and hours. And there was a lot of heavyweight guitar players there that night.
很多艺术家住在那儿。所以奥尔曼兄弟乐队的布奇·特拉克斯有一天晚上过来了，还有来自“面包”乐队的格里芬，以及曾经和约翰·列侬一起演奏的杰西·埃德·戴维斯，有一天晚上也过来了，我们即兴演奏了几个小时又几个小时。那天晚上有很多重量级的吉他手在那里。
And remember Butch wanted me to go back to Alabama and be the lead singer for this group, Cowboy. But that never happened. Creed, your life is amazing. Jenna, I don't know that we would have been hip enough to hang out there. We would not. Well, I have a card right here.
还记得布奇想让我回阿拉巴马州，做“牛仔”乐队的主唱吗？但这从未发生。克里德，你的生活太神奇了。珍娜，我不知道我们是否够时髦去那里混。我们不会。好吧，我这里有一张卡片。
Tell me. Seven minutes, 44 seconds. Creed, we have some PPC rivalry. Oh, I've got it down. Pam versus Angela. Angela Sass? Angela Sass, but also same category. Same category.
告诉我。7分44秒。克里德，我们有一些PPC（派对策划委员会）的竞争。哦，我记下来了。帕姆对阵安吉拉。安吉拉的傲慢？安吉拉的傲慢，但也属于同一类别。同一类别。
What? I get this. So my character says, what, you brought brownies? Like, what did you bring? And you're like, I brought brownies. Brownies. And like, but I brought cookies. Same category. Yeah.
什么？我明白了。所以我的角色说，什么，你带了布朗尼？你带了什么？然后你说，我带了布朗尼。布朗尼。然后就像，但我带了饼干。同一类别。是的。
Same category. You should have brought something savory. You know, Angela had a way. Is that what you say in the thing? Same category? I say same category. I remember that. Well, I mean, I feel like there's a backstory missing here. Did you assign me something other than brownies? I'm sure I did. That's your implication. Yes.
同一类别。你应该带点咸的。你知道，安吉拉有一种方式。那是你在那件事里说的吗？同一类别？我说同一类别。我记得那个。好吧，我的意思是，我觉得这里缺少一个背景故事。你有没有分配给我除了布朗尼以外的东西？我肯定有。那是你的暗示。是的。
You're implying that I went rogue and brought brownies instead of chips and dip. I clearly at some party planning- Don't you say where's the chips and dip or something? Yes. I clearly at some party planning committee meeting said, all right, I will make sugar cookies. Why don't you bring the dip and chips and then you show up with these fricking brownies. How dare you? Wait, Sam, can we see that? Those aren't chips and dip. No, I made brownies.
你在暗示我擅自行动，带了布朗尼而不是薯片和蘸酱。我显然在某个派对策划委员会会议上……你不是说薯片和蘸酱在哪里吗？是的。我显然在某个派对策划委员会会议上说，好吧，我会做糖饼干。你为什么不带蘸酱和薯片，然后你带着这些该死的布朗尼出现了。你怎么敢？等等，萨姆，我们能看那个吗？那些不是薯片和蘸酱。不，我做了布朗尼。
What? I'm just trying to figure out why you're sabotaging things. I made brownies. And I made cookies. Same category. All right, after watching that clip, I will admit I think Pam did go a little rogue. Clearly you assigned me chips and dip. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you. Same category.
什么？我只是想弄清楚你为什么要破坏事情。我做了布朗尼。我还做了饼干。同一类别。好吧，看完那个片段，我承认我认为帕姆确实有点擅自行动了。显然你分配给我的是薯片和蘸酱。谢谢。是的。谢谢。同一类别。
Yeah. Same category. All right. I needed to hear that because I think, Jenna, if it was your house and you were having a party, you would be like, hey, come on. Yeah. All right. Guys, I think we should go to a break,
是的。同一类别。好吧，我需要听到这个，因为我认为，珍娜，如果那是你的房子，你在开派对，你会说，嘿，拜托。是的。好吧。伙计们，我想我们应该休息一下，
and then we'll come back and finish the episode. All right. Creed, how are you doing? I'm doing wonderful. Oh my god, I love having you here, Creed. I do too. I do too. And we are back with my delightful neighbor
然后我们回来完成这一集。好吧。克里德，你怎么样？我感觉棒极了。哦天哪，我喜欢你在这里，克里德。我也喜欢。我也喜欢。我们回来了，和我可爱的邻居
and an office favorite, Creed Brown. Thank you. Creed, we're gonna make you come back on this podcast all the time. I hope you're ready. Yeah. You know what? We could carpool. We could.
以及办公室的最爱，克里德·布朗。谢谢。克里德，我们要让你一直来这个播客。希望你准备好了。是的。你知道吗？我们可以拼车。我们可以。
I could swing by and pick you up. You're like, oh my God, Angela, lurking, lurking these office ladies. You guys, do you remember the scene where Jim takes a phone call from a potential employer for Dwight and he does a Michael Scott impression. It's really good. John does a very good job. It's at eight minutes, 34 seconds. Oh, you've got the time code.
我可以顺路去接你。你就像，哦天哪，安吉拉，潜伏，潜伏在这些办公室女士身边。伙计们，你们记得吉姆接听一个潜在雇主给德怀特的电话，他模仿迈克尔·斯科特的那场戏吗？真的很好。约翰做得非常好。在8分34秒。哦，你有时间码。
Guys, is this when we find out that Michael's middle name is Gary? Oh, is this the first time it's said? Because he says Michael G Scott, Michael Gary Scott. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. Because later it was when we had the scene
伙计们，这是我们发现迈克尔的中间名是加里的时候吗？哦，这是第一次提到吗？因为他说迈克尔·G·斯科特，迈克尔·加里·斯科特。是的。我不知道。我不知道。因为后来是在我们有那场戏的时候，
where we showed him as a little boy and he doesn't get all the love that he wanted because he wanted a family. That's later, right? Yeah, yeah. Okay, that was Gary. We knew Gary there. That might be, that might be the first time.
我们展示他还是个小男孩，他没有得到他想要的所有的爱，因为他想要一个家庭。那是后面，对吧？是的，是的。好吧，那是加里。我们在那里知道是加里。那可能是，那可能是第一次。
I don't know. I'm putting it out there. Our fans will know. Our fans will let us know first time. I don't know. I'm putting it out there. Our fans will know. Our fans will let us know for sure. I loved the scene. I just thought that John crushed it as Michael Scott. And it also had the Jim and Pam air high five. The first air high five.
我不知道。我只是提出来。我们的粉丝会知道。我们的粉丝会告诉我们第一次。我不知道。我只是提出来。我们的粉丝会知道。我们的粉丝肯定会告诉我们。我喜欢那场戏。我只是觉得约翰演迈克尔·斯科特演得太棒了。而且还有吉姆和帕姆的空中击掌。第一次空中击掌。
Yes. I'm getting creeds getting misty eyed. I got, I literally, when I saw it, I think I audibly said out loud to no one, aw. Yeah, super cute. Okay, so I have a question about the air high five. Say it. So I was trying to do the air high five
是的。我看到克里德热泪盈眶了。我，我真的，当我看到它时，我想我大声对空气说，噢。是的，超级可爱。好吧，所以我有一个关于空中击掌的问题。说吧。所以我当时在尝试做空中击掌，
with my daughter, Isabelle, now granted. She's 11, I'm 48, maybe our timing's off. We couldn't get it our timing's off. We couldn't get it. It's difficult. You guys did it perfectly. Yeah. And you know what?
和我女儿伊莎贝尔一起，当然了。她11岁，我48岁，也许我们的时机不对。我们做不到，我们的时机不对。我们做不到。这很难。你们做得太完美了。是的。而且你知道吗？
We kind of did it perfectly the first time. It was meant to be. It was meant to be. That speaks to our chemistry, I believe. So shortly after this momentous air high five, very sadly, Pam tells Jim he should go for the job at Cumberland Mills. But the job is in Maryland and he is so hurt. This happens a lot with you guys.
我们第一次就做得近乎完美。这是命中注定的。这是命中注定的。我相信这说明了我们的化学反应。所以在这个重大的空中击掌之后不久，非常遗憾的是，帕姆告诉吉姆他应该去争取坎伯兰米尔斯的工作。但工作在马里兰州，他非常受伤。这种情况在你们身上发生过很多次。
Yeah. Him going off to do a job, a recurring theme, right? It is because he's, you know, later he's gonna go off to the other branch. And then later to New York and do that stuff with the sports thing, right? Yeah. It kept happening.
是的。他去工作，一个反复出现的主题，对吧？是的，因为他，你知道，后来他要去另一个分部。然后后来去纽约做那些体育相关的事情，对吧？是的。它一直在发生。
And then you go to art camp or school or... Art camp? I went to a university. Thank you very much. Art camp. Plaster of Paris making place. Geez. But yes, they constantly are being pushed together and pulled apart, right? Yeah, they are. Always, yeah. It's true. But sometimes just through a comment, we're seeing in this second season, in each episode, there seems to be a really
然后你去艺术营或学校或……艺术营？我去了一所大学。非常感谢。艺术营。石膏制作场所。天哪。但是的，他们不断地被推到一起又被拉开，对吧？是的，他们是。总是这样，是的。这是真的。但有时仅仅通过一个评论，我们在第二季中看到，在每一集中，似乎都有一个非常
sweet moment with Jim and Pam and then a moment where someone gets their feelings hurt a little bit. So many feelings. So many feelings. Feelings. But then at the end, Jim admits that if it weren't for Pam, he would take the job at Cumberland Mills because the pay is twice as much, it's a better job, yada, yada. So why is he staying? He just basically admitted why he stays at this job.
甜蜜的吉姆和帕姆的时刻，然后是一个有人受到一点伤害的时刻。太多的感情。太多的感情。感情。但最后，吉姆承认如果不是因为帕姆，他会接受坎伯兰米尔斯的工作，因为薪水是两倍，这是一份更好的工作，等等等等。所以他为什么要留下来？他基本上承认了他为什么留在这份工作上。
Yes. Yeah. What was the one where he admitted that crabs are his favorite food, so he was going to go to this Maryland. Was that Maryland? But that was it. Yeah. It was the crab. That was the crab thing. Yeah. Soft-shelled crabs are apparently one of his favorites.
是的。是的。那个他承认螃蟹是他最喜欢的食物，所以他要去马里兰州的是哪一个？那是马里兰州吗？但就是那个。是的。那是螃蟹。那是螃蟹的事。是的。软壳蟹显然是他的最爱之一。
Yes, exactly. Who knew? Well, he eats that tuna sandwich every day for lunch. So he is a seafood fan. So he just stinks all the time. I guess so. Jim kind of stinks. Andy could have called him crab if he wanted to.
是的，完全正确。谁知道呢？好吧，他每天午餐都吃金枪鱼三明治。所以他是个海鲜迷。所以他一直臭烘烘的。我想是吧。吉姆有点臭。安迪如果想的话可以叫他螃蟹。
Oh, crabby. Jim eats tuna sandwiches and Pam eats sour cream and onion chips. They're a match made. And I eat mung beans, apparently. Wow, what is there? The smells in this all day. They're a match made. And I eat mung beans apparently. Wow, what is there, the smells in this all. Smells and melts.
哦，螃蟹。吉姆吃金枪鱼三明治，帕姆吃酸奶油洋葱薯片。他们是天作之合。而我显然吃绿豆。哇，那里有什么？整天都有味道。他们是天作之合。而我显然吃绿豆。哇，那里有什么，所有的味道。味道和融化。
I know, yeah. Oh dear. All right, so finally Michael asks for Jim's help and he wants to do some role playing where he tries to fire someone and that is just a delicious scene. Did you enjoy that one? How did John get through it is what I wanna know.
我知道，是的。哦亲爱的。好吧，最后迈克尔寻求吉姆的帮助，他想做一些角色扮演，他试图解雇某人，那真是一场精彩的戏。你喜欢那一场吗？我想知道约翰是怎么演完的。
When like Steve is Michael is like, what are you doing? I'm gonna kill myself. And he's like, wait, is this you as you or who are you right now? What is happening? John has to check in. And this brings us to your big scene.
当史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔说，你在做什么？我要自杀了。然后他说，等等，这是你作为你，还是你现在是谁？发生了什么？约翰必须确认一下。这把我们带到了你的大戏。
Your big scene. Oh, here we are. This is it. After that scene, he calls you in and tell us, break it down for us, what was it like to sit in that chair and now you're gonna launch into Five Pages with Steve Carell? Right. I mean, I had never had Five Pages with Steve Carell, or Six and a Half, you said. Six and a Half. Six and a Half, originally. They may have cut it down, but it took a long, like hours to get through that thing. Yeah. And I mean, I never had more than a few lines with him one-on-one.
你的大戏。哦，我们到了。就是这个。在那场戏之后，他把你叫进去，告诉我们，为我们拆解一下，坐在那把椅子上，现在你要和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔演五页纸是什么感觉？对。我的意思是，我从来没有和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔演过五页纸，或者你说六页半。六页半。六页半，最初。他们可能删减了，但演完那东西花了很多时间，几个小时。是的。我的意思是，我和他一对一从来没有超过几句台词。
So yeah, let's hear about it. Well, first of all, there was a scene where I slowly take out the teeth, you know, and I resolve myself. I gird my loins, as it were. I stand up within a resolute and I march in like a Nesferatu, you know, with a purpose. Are these some of your notes that you wrote in your script for intention? No, no. This is just him storytelling, Jenna. It's the B story. It's the storytelling.
所以是的，让我们听听。好吧，首先，有一场戏是我慢慢地拿出牙齿，你知道，我下定决心。我束紧腰带，可以这么说。我站起来，坚定不移，像诺斯费拉图一样走进去，你知道，带着目的。这些是你写在剧本里关于意图的笔记吗？不，不。这只是他在讲故事，珍娜。这是B故事。这是讲故事。
I'm into the story right now. Yes, go. Exactly. So you march in. So I march in and then I remember I sit back like this and I cross my feet and I kind of houched down and I have my arms crossed because I'm protecting myself from attack like this. And he goes, well, I'll Creed, I just don't like this. I said, well, you want to leave?
我现在沉浸在故事里。是的，继续。完全正确。所以你走进去。所以我走进去，然后我记得我像这样向后坐，交叉双脚，我有点缩着，我双臂交叉，因为我在保护自己免受攻击，像这样。他说，好吧，克里德，我只是不喜欢这样。我说，好吧，你想离开吗？
He says, no, no, I don't. No, and yes, you do. No, no, I don't. You're the hardest person to fire ever. You want to leave? No, no, really, no, I know I'm very happy here. I said, Creed, I've got to fire somebody and it's got to be, well, then fire Devin.
他说，不，不，我不想。不，而且是的，你想。不，不，我不想。你是最难解雇的人。你想离开吗？不，不，真的，不，我知道我在这里很开心。我说，克里德，我必须解雇某人，而且必须是……好吧，那就解雇德文。
He's horrible and he's a job. I'm so much better at my job, and I'm doing the Creed voice right now too. He goes up a bitch, you know? And then I just fought, I just fought for my survival. And we kept doing it over and over and over, and finally, and Steve is so great. It's like, you all have done scenes with people
他很糟糕，他是个工作。我工作比他好得多，而且我现在也在用克里德的声音。他是个混蛋，你知道吗？然后我就战斗，我只是为了生存而战。我们一遍又一遍地做，最后，史蒂夫太棒了。就像，你们都和别人演过戏，
where it's forcing it, it's so hard to get through a scene. Working with Steven was like, he kept tossing me these big beach balls and I had a Nerf bat, which is easy. It was easy to hit those things, you know? God bless him. He's a very giving, giving person, you know? And when you're in scenes with him,
那种强迫性的，很难演完一场戏。和史蒂夫一起工作就像，他不断地扔给我这些巨大的沙滩球，而我有一个泡沫球棒，这很容易。击中那些东西很容易，你知道吗？上帝保佑他。他是一个非常慷慨、慷慨的人，你知道吗？当你和他演戏时，
he's so eager for you to get the laugh. He doesn't, some actors, guys out there, they want to get a laugh. They want that moment. And Steve is so eager for you to get the laugh. He doesn't, some actors, guys out there, they want to get the laugh. They want that moment. And Steve is so eager to share it and really just what makes the scene work is what he focuses on. But Dave Rogers later, he said,
他非常渴望让你得到笑声。他不会……有些演员，伙计们，他们想得到笑声。他们想要那个时刻。而史蒂夫非常渴望让你得到笑声。他不会……有些演员，伙计们，他们想得到笑声。他们想要那个时刻。而史蒂夫非常渴望分享它，真正让这场戏奏效的是他所关注的。但戴夫·罗杰斯后来，他说，
what made him laugh the most is when I stood up and he said, no, no, you're doing a good job. Good for you. That, that, that, that, that, that. I played. I love that. I played in my finger and all that stuff was just off the top of my head.
让他笑得最厉害的是当我站起来的时候，他说，不，不，你做得很好。为你感到高兴。那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个。我玩了。我喜欢那个。我玩了我的手指，所有那些东西都只是我即兴发挥的。
Yeah. When I rewatched it, I was like, oh, that is Creed. That is classic. That is just Creed being Creed. Yeah. Yeah. That is actually, yeah. Cause I feel like you've left me voicemails where you're like, hey, pumpkin, da, da, da,
是的。当我重看它时，我想，哦，那就是克里德。那是经典。那就是克里德做克里德。是的。是的。那实际上是，是的。因为我觉得你给我留过语音留言，你说，嘿，南瓜，哒，哒，哒，
da, da, da. I was just stuttering perhaps too. But you were doing a bit. I was doing a bit, yeah. No. But still I look at that with fond memories. It was a stuttering perhaps too. You were doing a bit. I was doing a bit, yeah. No, but still I look at that with fond memories. It was a great, and I thank Steve so much for being so gracious as an actor to work with. So after that scene, Michael does fire Devin in a much shorter scene.
哒，哒，哒。我可能也结巴了。但你在演戏。我在演戏，是的。不。但即便如此，我还是带着美好的回忆看着它。那是一场伟大的戏，我非常感谢史蒂夫作为一名演员能如此亲切地与我合作。所以在那场戏之后，迈克尔在另一场短得多的戏中解雇了德文。
Devin gets so angry. He announces to the office, if anyone wants to join me at Poor Richard's Bar, Poor Richard's Bar, is this the first mention of Poor Richard's Bar? Well, he says he gives him a chili. He gives him a, she says- Michael gives him a chili coupon. Chili coupon, yeah. Which is a nice nod back to the Dundies. Yeah, yeah.
德文变得非常生气。他向办公室宣布，如果有人想和我一起去可怜理查德酒吧，可怜理查德酒吧，这是第一次提到可怜理查德酒吧吗？好吧，他说他给了他一份辣椒。他给了他一个，她说……迈克尔给了他一张辣椒优惠券。辣椒优惠券，是的。这对邓迪奖是一个很好的致敬。是的，是的。
He rips it up. He rips it up, yeah. But have we, because we end up mentioning Poor Richard's Bar over and over again, and we go there eventually, but have we mentioned it yet? Oh, in the basketball episode. I think Darrell suggests that we all get drinks at Poor Richards. Okay, in that scene though,
他把它撕了。他把它撕了，是的。但我们，因为我们最终一遍又一遍地提到可怜理查德酒吧，我们最终去了那里，但我们提到过它吗？哦，在篮球那一集。我想达里尔建议我们都去可怜理查德喝一杯。好吧，在那场戏里，
where Devin invites everyone to Poor Richards, there's three people he does not invite. Oh, yeah, you're right. He lists a bunch of names. Who does he not? It's very personal. It's personal. Who are they? He does not invite Michael. Of course. He does not bunch of names. Who does he know? It's very personal. It's personal. Who are they? He does not invite Michael.
德文邀请大家去可怜理查德，有三个人他没有邀请。哦，是的，你是对的。他列出了一堆名字。他没有邀请谁？这非常个人化。这是个人化的。他们是谁？他没有邀请迈克尔。当然。他没有邀请一堆名字。他没有邀请谁？这非常个人化。这是个人化的。他们是谁？他没有邀请迈克尔。
Of course. He does not invite Dwight. He does not invite Angela. He doesn't invite you? No. Why? They're just made... It's arbitrary.
当然。他没有邀请德怀特。他没有邀请安吉拉。他没有邀请你？不。为什么？他们只是……这是随意的。
It's an arbitrary... Why not you? I'm sure I've been bitchy to him at some point. I'm sure. Or maybe he just knew you wouldn't go. Maybe so. He might have had a crush on you too. Oh, come on.
这是一个随意的……为什么不是你？我肯定在某个时候对他很刻薄。我肯定。或者也许他只是知道你不会去。也许吧。他可能也暗恋你。哦，拜托。
Oh, he might have, you never know. So he leaves and he smashes a pumpkin. There we go. Pumpkin, pumpkin. And when we go downstairs, we see Hank, the security guy, at the security desk who was played by Hugh Dane. God rest his peace. Yes, who passed away a couple of years ago.
哦，他可能暗恋，你永远不知道。所以他离开了，砸了一个南瓜。我们到了。南瓜，南瓜。当我们下楼时，我们看到汉克，保安，在保安台，由休·戴恩饰演。愿他安息。是的，几年前去世了。
He was so nice. Yeah. Just a sweetheart. And so great as Hank. His delivery was always perfect. Amazing. Is this the first time we see Hank at the security desk? I think so.
他太好了。是的。简直是个甜心。作为汉克太棒了。他的台词总是完美的。太神奇了。这是我们第一次在保安台看到汉克吗？我想是。
It has to be. You guys leave to go to the dojo. Yeah. But I don't think we saw him there. You don't see him, no. Well, it's brilliant because there he is, and he's sitting there, and it's another example of introducing a character in an episode where they don't speak, but they will eventually.
一定是。你们离开去道场了。是的。但我不认为我们在那里看到他。你没看到他，不。好吧，这很棒，因为他就在那里，他坐在那里，这是在这一集中引入一个角色，他们不说话，但最终会说话的另一个例子。
Yeah. They will come back. He did that with so many people. He did that with Craig in the warehouse in the Alliance. You just see him in the background watching Dwight pop out of the box. Creed, of course, you were in the warehouse in the Alliance. You just see him in the background watching Dwight pop out of the box. Creed, of course, you were in the background forever.
是的。他们会回来的。他用很多人做过这件事。他在“联盟”那一集中在仓库里对克雷格做过。你只是在背景中看到他看着德怀特从盒子里跳出来。克里德，当然，你在背景中待了很久。
And then now Hugh Dane in the background is the security officer. Just so thoughtful. And this thing that I love about our show and we've talked about Creed is that Greg had the audience just start in the middle. He doesn't explain things to you. You discover it as you go.
然后现在休·戴恩在背景中是保安。太体贴了。关于我们的节目，我喜欢的一点，我们谈论过克里德，是格雷格让观众从中间开始。他不会向你解释事情。你边看边发现。
It's not spoon fed information. Yes. I love that. Well, I don't think we can end this episode without talking about Michael's list of former costumes. Oh, please list them. Okay. He's really, really bummed the camera crew wasn't there the Halloween before when he was Janet Jackson's boob. Very topical. He's really bummed you guys missed it when he was Janet Jackson's boob, very topical. He's really bummed you guys missed it when he was Monica Lewinsky's dress. Twice. Yeah, twice.
这不是填鸭式的信息。是的。我喜欢那样。好吧，我认为如果不谈论迈克尔以前的服装清单，我们就不能结束这一集。哦，请列出来。好的。他真的很，很沮丧摄像组不在去年的万圣节，当时他是珍妮·杰克逊的胸部。非常应景。他真的很沮丧你们错过了他扮成珍妮·杰克逊的胸部的时候，非常应景。他真的很沮丧你们错过了他扮成莫妮卡·莱温斯基的裙子的时候。两次。是的，两次。
And then he was Monica Lewinsky the year before. And then before that he was OJ Simpson. So very topical, great costumes that he was really sad the camera crew missed. I know you're gonna wanna talk about the very end with Michael and the trick-or-treaters because it's just such a touching moment. All right, I cried.
然后前一年他是莫妮卡·莱温斯基。在那之前他是OJ·辛普森。所以非常应景，很棒的服装，他真的很伤心摄像组错过了。我知道你会想谈谈最后迈克尔和那些要糖果的孩子，因为那是一个非常感人的时刻。好吧，我哭了。
Every time I watch it. I did too, I did too. Every time. I was loving the show and then when it got to that episode, it just killed me. I said, oh my God, this is a perfect episode. It's one of the great ones, you know? Yes, at the end of the episode, Michael goes home
每次我看它。我也哭了，我也哭了。每次。我喜欢这个节目，然后当它到那一集时，它简直杀了我。我说，哦天哪，这是一集完美的剧集。它是伟大的剧集之一，你知道吗？是的，在这一集的结尾，迈克尔回家了，
and you see him sitting alone, very lonely, on the couch. And then the doorbell rings and there are trick-or-treaters at the door. And there was a big debate on set about how exactly this scene should play out, about whether or not the kids should be nice to Michael or if they should be annoyed by Michael, how Michael should be with the kids, should he be off-putting, should he be kind. And the writers and producers also, well, they also discussed if he should be happy or sad while handing out the candy. And they decided that they were going to start on that spy shot of Michael looking sad and lonely, all alone on Halloween night.
你看到他独自一人，非常孤独地坐在沙发上。然后门铃响了，门口有要糖果的孩子。关于这场戏应该如何进行，孩子们是否应该对迈克尔好，或者他们是否应该被迈克尔烦，迈克尔应该如何对待孩子，他应该是令人反感的，还是应该是友善的，片场有很大的争论。编剧和制片人也讨论了他分发糖果时应该是快乐还是悲伤。他们决定从迈克尔看起来悲伤和孤独的那个间谍镜头开始，在万圣节之夜独自一人。
But when he gets to the door, I'm going to cry saying it, he lights up, he makes his silly jokes, the kids laugh. The kids love him. Love him. They love him. And it ends on him making a connection. I just think it is the most kind and heartbreaking, wonderful scene. I think it's moments like this that make The Office so special.
但当他走到门口时，说出来我要哭了，他亮了起来，他讲他愚蠢的笑话，孩子们笑了。孩子们喜欢他。喜欢他。他们喜欢他。最后他建立了一个联系。我只是认为这是最善良、最令人心碎、最美妙的场景。我认为正是这样的时刻让《办公室》如此特别。
We just spend an entire episode kind of laughing at Michael Scott or finding him annoying, but then in the end, he just breaks your heart with his vulnerability. Take them all. Don't they drop them? Don't worry. Take them all. Take them all. Take them all.
我们只是花了一整集的时间嘲笑迈克尔·斯科特或者觉得他很烦人，但最后，他用他的脆弱打破了你的心。全拿走。他们不会掉吗？别担心。全拿走。全拿走。全拿走。
Take them all. Take them all. And they love him. All yours, yeah. That's the first time we saw him just so loving. Really? Don't you think so? At that moment, we saw his heart.
全拿走。全拿走。他们喜欢他。全是你的，是的。那是我们第一次看到他如此充满爱心。真的吗？你不觉得吗？在那一刻，我们看到了他的心。
We saw his heart come out there at that moment. Yeah. Well, and you... Tore me up. Now, tore me up, and you have to think that Michael is somewhere being a great dad. Yeah. He's a great dad. And I wish we could see that. That's the one thing when we talk about a reunion, obviously, you know, we don't want to tread on hallowed ground that is the office, and we don't want to mess with anything that everyone loves so much.
我们在那一刻看到了他的真心。是的。嗯，而且你……让我感动得落泪。真的，让我感动得落泪，你不得不认为迈克尔在某个地方一定是个很棒的爸爸。是的。他是个很棒的爸爸。我真希望我们能看到那一幕。当我们谈论重聚时，有一件事很明显，你知道，我们不想践踏《办公室》这片神圣的土地，我们不想破坏大家如此热爱的一切。
But boy, I would love to see where some of these people are and I would love to see Michael as a dad. Yes, yes. Do you agree that when you watch that scene, I think more than any other scene I can recall, I see Steve. Yes. That is Steve handing out candy.
但是天哪，我很想看看这些人现在都在哪里，我也很想看看迈克尔当爸爸的样子。是的，是的。你同意吗，当你观看那个场景时，我想比我能回想起的任何其他场景都更能看到史蒂夫本人。是的。那是史蒂夫在分发糖果。
Absolutely, yes. That's the kind of just kindhearted gentleman that he is. Sweet man. And I think that's part of the reason too, why it hits you that hard, Jenna, because we see our friend and we see the kind person he is that gets to shine through, which often as Michael Scott does not.
绝对同意，是的。他就是那种心地善良的绅士。甜心。我想这也是为什么那一幕让你如此感动的部分原因，珍娜，因为我们看到了我们的朋友，看到了他身上闪耀的善良品质，而迈克尔·斯科特这个角色往往不会展现出来。
No, he does not. That's true. Well, I have one little final piece of trivia. All right. In the credits at the end as it rolls, over the Dedal-D logo, which Dedal-D is Greg's company, his daughter Haley actually drew the picture that says Dedal-D when she was little.
不，他不会。那是真的。好吧，我还有一个最后的小花絮。好的。在片尾字幕滚动时，在Dedal-D标志上方，Dedal-D是格雷格的公司，他女儿海莉小时候画了那个写着Dedal-D的图片。
You hear, and it's the only time it ever happens, Dwight's voice say, quiet you. Oh, Angela. Really? But do we know why that happened? I think they loved it. They pulled it from earlier in the episode when Dwight is the Sith Lord. Is that the only time that they-
你听到了，这是唯一一次出现这种情况，德怀特的声音说，安静点。哦，安吉拉。真的吗？但我们知道为什么会发生这种情况吗？我想他们很喜欢。他们从剧集早些时候德怀特扮演西斯尊主的那段里截取出来的。那是他们唯一一次……
It's the only time there's dialogue over Dedal-D. Wow. Oh, I'm kind of moved by that. That's kind of cool, right? Yeah. Quiet you. Quiet you. Quiet you. Well, we did it, guys.
这是唯一一次在Dedal-D标志上出现对话。哇。哦，我被感动了。这很酷，对吧？是的。安静点。安静点。安静点。好吧，我们做到了，伙计们。
We did it. We did it. That was the Halloween episode creed. Thank you. Thank you so much for coming. But before you go, will you tell us what are you up to now? What are you doing?
我们做到了。我们做到了。那是万圣节那一集，克里德。谢谢。非常感谢你的到来。但在你走之前，能告诉我们你现在在忙什么吗？你在做什么？
You have an album and you're touring. I'm touring. I was in Europe, UK, and in Scandinavia for a month, touring and doing shows. in Europe, UK and Scandinavia for a month touring and doing shows, had like seven, I'm bragging now, seven sold out shows to the UK. Went great, I'm off to Australia, New Zealand in February. And then you did the whole East Coast too because I was texting with you and you were like, yeah.
你有一张专辑，而且正在巡演。我在巡演。我在欧洲、英国和斯堪的纳维亚待了一个月，巡演并进行表演。在欧洲、英国和斯堪的纳维亚巡演了一个月，做了演出，我有七场——我现在在吹牛了——七场在英国售罄的演出。进展很顺利，二月份我要去澳大利亚和新西兰。然后你也跑了整个东海岸，因为我当时在给你发短信，你说，是的。
Then I did the East Coast, had a great tour there too. And the fans, and I want to thank all the Office fans for coming out and supporting my character and my music and it truly means a lot. I'm having my second childhood now doing this. And by the way, I have a surprise for you ladies. What is it? I brought, which I think may be the single, if there's going to be a single from my... I'm going to play you a little snippet if you'd like. Yes, please.
然后我跑了东海岸，那里的巡演也很棒。粉丝们，我想感谢所有《办公室》的粉丝出来支持我的角色和我的音乐，这对我意义重大。我现在正在经历我的第二次童年。顺便说一句，我给你们两位女士带了一个惊喜。是什么？我带来了，我认为这可能是单曲，如果我的专辑里会有单曲的话……如果你愿意，我可以给你们放一小段。是的，请。
Of the album. Can we do this in there? Can I play it right now for you? And you guys, before he plays the song, I just wanna encourage you, if Creed is coming to a town near you, go see his show. It is fantastic. And apparently he also makes fun of me during it. Quite a bit, Angela, yes. And we are trying to figure out one of your locations where I can come on stage and give it to you right back.
专辑里的。我们可以在这里放吗？我现在能给你们放吗？你们大家，在他播放这首歌之前，我只想鼓励你们，如果克里德要到你们附近的城市，一定要去看他的演出。非常精彩。而且显然他在演出期间还会取笑我。相当多，安吉拉，是的。我们正在设法确定你的一个演出地点，我可以上台回敬你。
Oh, we... Where can people find the schedule? Creedbratton stage and give it to you right back. Where can people find the schedule? Creedbratton.com. We love you Creed. All right, let's hear it. All right, here we go. And the ride. You taught me how, you taught me then How I could one day be your friend Just don't lie Don't control it by and by We'll be side by side
哦，我们……人们在哪里可以找到时间表？克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）上台回敬你。人们在哪里可以找到时间表？Creedbratton.com。我们爱你，克里德。好的，让我们听听看。好的，开始了。还有那段旅程。你教我如何，你当时教我，有一天我如何能成为你的朋友。只要别撒谎，别去控制它，迟早我们会并肩同行。
We'll be side by side Forward, center, right All right, that's that song. There it is gang. What do you think? Well, Angela's sobbing. I just started crying. The song is so beautiful Creed, but also, and I totally am emotional, but oh my God, it might be too emotional. Well, you know what? Do you ever have just like a wave hit you where you're like, you know you're in a special moment? Yeah. And it just hit me. Well, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like and I'm facing my best friend who is now my boss lady business partner and I'm so proud of us and this journey we've taken together and then I just love you Creed. Oh I love you sweetie. You're like you know family family. Well I've I've ladies and gentlemen when
我们会并肩同行，向前，居中，向右。好了，就是那首歌。伙计们，就是这样。你们觉得怎么样？嗯，安吉拉在啜泣。我刚开始哭。这首歌太美了，克里德，而且，我完全被触动了，天哪，这可能太感人了。嗯，你知道吗？你有没有过那种感觉，就像一阵浪潮袭来，你知道自己正处于一个特别的时刻？是的。它刚刚击中了我。嗯，我感觉，我感觉，我感觉……我正面对着我最好的朋友，她现在是我的老板、商业伙伴，我为我们感到骄傲，为我们一起走过的这段旅程感到自豪，然后我真的很爱你，克里德。哦，我也爱你，亲爱的。你就像，你知道，家人，家人。嗯，女士们先生们，当
I the last album I did I had a song called More Than You Know and I one of the first people I ever played it for was for you and Josh you you know, at your house. I came over and acoustically played it, you know, and she started crying. I knew I had a winner then. Well, Creed, some of my favorite memories on the set were at lunchtime when you would play guitar and Ed would play banjo. Ed's trailer was next to mine. You'd go in his trailer and the two of you would play through my lunch. And you guys would to mine. You'd go in his trailer and the two of you would play through my lunch. And I just loved it.
我上一张专辑里有一首歌叫《More Than You Know》，我最早给听的人之一就是你和乔什，你知道，在你们家。我过去用原声吉他弹奏了它，你知道，她开始哭了。那时我就知道我成功了。嗯，克里德，我在片场最美好的回忆之一就是午餐时间，你会弹吉他，埃德会弹班卓琴。埃德的拖车就在我隔壁。你会去他的拖车里，你们两个会在我的午餐时间一直弹奏。你们会去我的拖车里。你们两个会在我的午餐时间一直弹奏。我真的很喜欢。
And you guys would come over and stick your hand in and listen. We'd come over and hang out. For years, my alarm clock is banjo music because it would make me think of you guys. And sometimes, especially when I was pregnant, if we had a little break, I might take a cat nap and I'd wake up to banjo music. And it was like so pleasing that I made my alarm clock banjo. Cause I thought,
你们会过来把手伸进来听。我们会过来一起玩。多年来，我的闹钟一直是班卓琴音乐，因为它会让我想起你们。有时，特别是我怀孕的时候，如果我们有短暂的休息，我可能会打个盹，然后被班卓琴音乐唤醒。这太令人愉悦了，所以我把闹钟设成了班卓琴。因为我想，
oh, maybe I won't wake up grumpy. Ed and I had so much fun. He's a, he's a great banjo player. I haven't played with him in a long time because he, we work in all the time, but I would love to. Oh yeah. You guys were great together. Well, thank you again. Thank you so much for having me. My dear friends. Creed, can we end with a final fan question? Yes, of course. This is from Tim Blair. Tim asked, do you have a favorite Creed line
哦，也许我醒来时就不会那么暴躁了。埃德和我玩得很开心。他是个很棒的班卓琴手。我已经很久没和他一起玩了，因为我们一直在工作，但我很想。哦，是的。你们在一起很棒。嗯，再次感谢你。非常感谢你的到来，我亲爱的朋友。克里德，我们能以一个最后的粉丝问题结束吗？是的，当然。这是来自蒂姆·布莱尔的问题。蒂姆问，你整部剧里最喜欢克里德的哪句台词？
from the whole show? Which one's Pam? Ah! Ah! Which question, Pam? Yes. I could say, gosh, I don't know. It probably would be someone making soup or which one's Pam.
哪一个是帕姆？啊！啊！什么问题，帕姆？是的。我可以回答，天哪，我不知道。可能是关于某人做汤的那句，或者是“哪一个是帕姆”。
But I think actually I would have to be... In the 60s, I made love to many, many women, often outdoors in the rain and the mud. It's possible a man slipped in. There'd be no way of knowing. Yes. Yes. Applause from the booth. And that is how you end an episode, my friend.
但我认为实际上我不得不选……在60年代，我与许多许多女性发生过关系，经常是在户外的雨中和泥地里。有可能有个男人混进来了。根本无法知道。是的。是的。来自录音室的掌声。这就是你结束一集的方式，我的朋友。
Thank you, Fred and Bee. Thank you, Creed. Oh, everyone, please join us next week when we will be talking about the fight. The fight. Yeah. We'll miss you, Creed. You have to come back. Oh, I'd love to come back.
谢谢，弗雷德和比。谢谢，克里德。哦，大家，请下周加入我们，届时我们将讨论《打架》那一集。《打架》。是的。我们会想念你的，克里德。你一定要回来。哦，我很乐意回来。
Okay. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva.
好的。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。
Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。